[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et tous et bienvenue
sur tv 78 nous sommes dans la salle de
spectacle la merise attrape pour vous
commenter la 20e et oui déjà 20e édition
du cycle mythe le championnat
intercollèges de match d'improvisation
théâtrale un événement organisé préparé
concocté mijoté par la compagnie déclic
théâtre ce soir nous vous proposons la
retransmission des demi finales et de la
finale de ce championnat
dans quelques instants des collégiennes
et des collégiens de saint quentin en
yvelines vont jouer sous vos yeux ébahis
quelques saynètes sorti tout droit de
leur imagination
une belle soirée en perspective pour
m'accompagner ce soir un spécialiste de
l'improvisation théâtrale ces libyens
meyer mont-saint-aignan comme ça alors
ça va super avec nous pour décortiquer
analyser expliquer toutes les ficelles
de l'improvisation de ce que vous allez
voir il ya des trucs à connaître
mais si vous voulez peut-être un novice
dans cet art est ce que vous pourriez
vous présenter en calcul mots aux
téléspectatrices
du coup moi c'est lilian comédiens
professionnels du cou attaché aussi à
déclic théâtre j'ai commencé l'impro il
ya déjà quelques années à un pro net à
plaisir j'ai rejoint l'équipe
professionnelle n'a pas un an l'équipe
adulte
dedeclic les épices ya quelques années
je suis comédien pour déclic théâtre
depuis trois ans maintenant
voilà et puis vous intervenez voilà au
prij end éco déjà qu'on va voir pas qui
ne sont peut-être pas la soie non mais
c'est ça mais moi j'ai intervenu aussi
dans l'est dans les collèges tout au
long de l'année dans certains collèges
sur les quatorze qui font partie du
cycle 8 cette année
alors qui succédera c'est la question
que vous posez j'en suis sur les liens
qui succédera au collège dans la mare au
sol à coignières qui a remporté le
trophée l'année dernière vous le saurez
dans à peu près deux heures des quatre
collèges qualifié pour les demi-finales
sont donc le collège de la mare au sol
de coignières le collège du village
attrape le collège alexandre dumas de
maurepas et enfin le collège des prés
de mon team et parthenay qui était déjà
finaliste l'année dernière demi
finalistes pardon s2000 sont pas arrivés
en finale
non c'était l'agio l'agio la mare aux
songes exactement l'âge de l'avs a reçu
c'était une très belle finale d'ailleurs
le collège gagarine avait fini 3e et
puis le collège des prés avait fini
quatrième à ce que vous pourriez nous
rappeler parce qu'évidemment il tombe
pas du ciel elle est jeune qu'on va voir
jouer dans quelques instants là ils ont
suivi des ateliers tout au long de
l'année puis se sont rencontrés déjà
c'est un showman octobre exactement fait
à partir de la rentrée
du coup les différents intervenants
viennent dans les collèges pour donner
des ateliers d'improvisation sur des
heures à aménager le midi ou après les
cours dans les différents collèges et
une fois qu'ils sont bien préparés on
les suit toute l'année dont ils ont des
rendez-vous des matchs tout au long de
l'année il ya un premier match pour une
première approche où le collège joue
entre soi entre guillemets devant le
public parce que c'est pas évident il
faut déjà qu'ils aient une première
approche du public au sein de leur
propre collège ensuite une fois que ça
s'est passé quelques mois après on fait
rencontrer les collèges d'entre eux se
rencontrer entre eux pour qu'ils
puissent voir d'autres choses dans un
collège tierces un collège neutre et
après ça on continue à les préparer tout
au long de l'année et il ya le fameux
tournoi de qualification au prisme du
coup là où ils font ils se rencontrent
tous il ya des poules de cinq équipes
on essaye de les faire se rencontrer un
maximum jusqu'à jusqu'au final de ce
soir alors vous avez donné voilà
beaucoup d'indications sur les ateliers
sur les rencontres qui a besoin je
remarque que vous utilisez le terme aux
rencontres
oui oui puisque match d'improvisation
c'est donc rencontre en anglais et sait
jamais on ne joue jamais l'un contre
l'autre
on joue toujours avec l'autre puisque la
majorité des improvisations vous verrez
seront mixtes on vous expliquera sa et
donc du coup le but c'est de faire le
meilleur le plus beau spectacle possible
pour le public
la victoire n'est qu'accessoire dans
tout ce jeu là alors justement vous avez
parlé de ce tournoi de qualification qui
s'est déroulé les 18 et 19 avril dernier
au prix smile en cours c'est aussi un
gros spectacle sur deux jours donc voilà
à l'issue de sa voix on a tiré allées
envahies de philosophe on à la tirer la
substantifique moelle qui va se
présenter dans quelques instants devant
vous donc je redonne les quatre équipes
qualifiées pour ce soir l'équipe de la
mare au sol de coignières qui jouera en
bleu l'équipe de trappes
du coup représenté par le collège le
village du cou qui jouera en rouge
le collège des prés de montigny le
bretonneux qui jouera en faire et puis
le collège alexandre dumas de maurepas
qui jouera jaune
on va les voir arriver ça quelques
instants c'est ça mon avion la personne
qu'on va voir les grands première mon
avis ce sera la mc la maîtresse de
cérémonie de ce voilà qui est donc
laetitia biche qui nous vient de paris
en preuve
voilà qui est aussi une comédienne
christensen et jean rolin fessionnels
acheteurs mon lit on entend le trouver
là ça commence à chauffer way à les
musiciens là on allait me un circuit
assez important aussi un vrai spectacle
à yahoo il ya tout un show présenté avec
qui tout est important que cela rebute
le mc les musiciens tout ça pour ça va
la merise ouais c'est pas mal ce match
pas mal je sens que vous pouvez faire un
peu plus comment ça va la mairie
[Applaudissements]
pour les facile à lire
[Musique]
on
attention sous le nez
bon
à toi
pour le bois dix ans
oui
c'est la première voilà c'est la
première rencontre avec le public donc
des musiciens sont très importants aux
olives et ses noyaux
c'est ça qui vont déserter le public
voilà les chauffer un petit peu pour les
préparer on allait mettre un peu dans
l'ambiance
c'est ça le but de toute façon cette
chauffer le public l'obligé brad
l'obligé lui demander gentiment de crier
d'applaudir pour déjà créé chauffer le
public c'est ça c'est déjà créé une
espèce de dopamine ou quelque chose pour
qu ils soient déjà il est le cerveau
dans un petit fauteuil avant l'entrée
des joueurs et qu'ils soient déjà dans
l'ambiance
et puis on va le voir le public un rôle
important très attendu match
d'improvisation retard des petits c'est
donc le public qui qui votent à la fin
des improvisations pour désigner le
vainqueur
à la fois la fin des matches la main
droite comme à gauche et on y va tous
ensemble
[Musique]
quoi
aulas
[Musique]
ah ah
ah ah ah bon
[Musique]
très bien alors si près mais l'un des
messieurs messieurs et mesdames nous
allons accueillir comme il se doit notre
maîtresse
c'est fini je me demande y a clamé la
charmante la délicieuse
vic là
[Applaudissements]
tout à l'heure laetitia
[Musique]
baa
[Applaudissements]
ja
[Musique]
le cycle it championnat intercollèges de
match d'improvisation théâtrale
organisée par la compagnie déclic
théâtre ou pas peu dire très fort et oui
20 ans 20 ans déjà 20 ans de partage 20
ans des changes
vingt ans de plaisir vingt ans que des
collégiens des collégiennes vous enivre
de leur imaginaire de collège en collège
et de théâtre en théâtre depuis des
dizaines d'années des générations
entières d'improvisateur et
improvisatrice ont usé leur pantalon de
survêtement sur ses bancs on transpirait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de sueur mais
pas seulement
aussi avec leur imaginaire pour en faire
sortir des idées farfelues belle et
grande
certains certains sont devenus connus
mais alors début je vous prie croire que
le trac la trouille les chocottes les
pétoches était bien présent comme les
joueurs de ce soir mais une seule chose
les réunissait autour de cette patinoire
celle envie de vous surprendre encore et
encore alors ce que vous avez envie
d'être surpris ce soir
justement ça tombe bien parce qu'ils
vont avoir besoin de vous de vous
applaudissements de vos encouragements
de votre amour bienveillant alors une
question me brûle les lèvres
est-ce que vous êtes prêts publics à
faire tout ça coup alors les viandes la
maîtresse de cerveau en deux clans salah
rôle important puisque c'est elle qui
donne un petit peu le tempo de la 2 de
la soirée elle explique au public un peu
ce qui se passe dans la patache c'est ça
c'est ça dans la pâte est donc la
patinoire avant c'est ça ouais donc du
coup et entre les entre les impros elle
va expliquer les catégories s'il y en a
larbitre parfois s'il fait des fautes
donc elle va avoir aussi la possible de
les expliquer au public qui ne connaît
pas tous par coeur et donc oui à la ce
rôle là et puis de relancer le public de
les faire applaudir de garder un rythme
plutôt n'ont que peu ces rencontres
donc vous êtes notre mc de la télé c'est
le collège a marre au sol de coignières
[Applaudissements]
ces câbles trop équipes viennent pour
tenter de remporter le titre tant
convoité
jacques atlan dit enfin il ya de
l'ambiance je crois qu'ils sont ils sont
complets ce soir il ya 500 perceptible
au risque qu'il y avait il ya du monde
il ya du brouillard
c'est pour ça que j'ai du mal à vous
entendre quelquefois dont voici les
téléspectateurs at elle expliqué me vois
m'approcher de vous j'ai pas de problème
d'audition
ce qui a beaucoup de bruit il ya
beaucoup d'effets difficile de tout anti
ça commence alors qu'on vient nous
rappeler le cup qui vient d'utiliser les
surfeurs égal voire et réglementaires ça
consiste
et là pourquoi un échauffement alors en
fait ceux ci on doit tout reprendre le
match d'improvisation sait qu allez vous
le voyez là sur le hockey sur glace
puisque ça nous vient du québec et du
coup avant que quand vous voyez un match
de hockey les joueurs viennent avant le
match pour taper dans le palais avec la
grosse et tout ça et donc on a repris sa
aussi dans le match d'improvisation
donc les joueurs viennent pendant 3 5
minutes s'échauffer sans leur maillot
tous ensemble au milieu de la patinoire
ça a plusieurs effets ça allait fait
déjà pas de faire applaudir le public et
aussi pour les comédiens c'est une bonne
chose c'est une première approche du
public et ça permet de relâcher cette
pression est comme ça quand on arrive
dans le match on a déjà eu une approche
du public on a déjà voilà ça permet de
trouver un peu la pesée avant de se
mettre au boulot derrière
et mise en route donc c'est ça et en
poitou charentes quand on jette un petit
coup d'oeil sur la nature les visages
sur les les expressions il ya déjà des
petites personnalités qui qui se détache
et qui y sont en jeu en fait c'est ça
oui c'est déjà ça fait partie du
spectacle 1,7 à l'échauffement mais
c'est déjà une partie du spectacle
ils sont déjà tous je le vois là quand
même très concentré tu as ça c'est
quelque chose qui est assez connu oui
pendant l'échauffement comment ça
s'appelle c'est le cocktail également le
cocktail peut vous laisser découvrir
[Musique]
voilà le cocktail du coup ils sont à une
soirée très regardé et dès que la
musique s'arrête ils doivent regarder le
public dont les jo gens en les regardant
de près
de chasse ce qui est sympa puisque on
l'entend dans le public des prénoms qui
sont lancés pour la droite c'est celle
ecopole écueil a déjà coulé les aides
relatifs à l'eau si on pourra évidemment
leurs camarades c'est ce que viennent
les encourager évidemment mais au moment
du vote ils doivent évidemment voter non
pas pour l'heure à nier ou pour leurs
familles mais pour l'équipe qui ont
privé les plus longues l'entraîneur
et de l'esprit qui règne aura sa place
dès la dgal son impartialité
il ya un vrai changement d'ambiance à
l'entrée leur bureau pour tous jeunes
sont accueillis noir larvée
[Musique]
pourias anonyme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu
alors vous l'avez entendu la scéno n ya
qu il fait partie du projet depuis sa
création
donc ça fait 20 ans qu'il est présent
qu'il est à l'organisation de ce
championnat intercollèges et l'arp
ultra-haute vraiment capital
pour le moment il ya deux grandes
fonctions à l'arbitré en fait un match
d'improvisation
il est là déjà pour signifier les fautes
puisqu'il arrive sur n'est due qu'au
l'improvisation on avoue on peut penser
qu'on a le droit de tout faire mais il
faut quand même certaines règles donc il
là pour les appliquer les faire
remarquer au public si elle il faut que
le public soit au courant que ce qu'il a
vu n'était pas normal avec l'équipe
d'alexandre dumas de maurepas qui jouera
en zone 1,6 sur un an
le 1er janvier bras les contrôleurs
c'est la capitaine d'un soir
batna
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
benoît l'egypte est garantie pour tous
ceux qui jouent en verre et qui sera
coaché une marge entre le vide charolais
pas
[Musique]
3 continuons avec les rouges contre la
prusse y en avait
[Applaudissements]
paris
et
[Musique]
thiam était le mondial
en soldes
[Applaudissements]
parution
[Musique]
parti
[Applaudissements]
car
[Musique]
et ce sont les collèges le village la
mare au sol qui vont débuter cette
première demi finale
le premier coup de sifflet de l'arbitré
bulgare des recommandations cher public
en ce qui concerne votre participation à
la fin de chaque impro c'est vous qui
vaudrait à l'aide du karting qui nous a
été distribué à l'entrée
celui ci voilà qu'est ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure
oui la maîtresse de cérémonie est en
train d'expliquer un petit peu comment
on procède au vote
donc c'est très important pour le public
parce que c'est public qui décide qui va
choisir quel improvisation lui a le plus
plu je sais ça alors là qu'est
l'improvisation mais quelle équipe est
la plus remarquée à la fin de chaque
improvisation
le public du coup à deux faces et ils
votent la face correspondante à l'équipe
pour l'équipe qui lui a plus plus fort
que ça soit qu'il a plus fait rire que
lui a apporté le plus d'émotions qui a
fait le plus de construction dans
l'histoire en fonction de l'année
conscience de chaque chacune des
personnes en public et vote
individuellement et on voit quelle
majorité se détache on le prend en
fonction aux équipes jusqu'à désigner un
vainqueur à la fin du match
n'importe pas chez soi on ne vit pas sur
son frigo on le rend oui ça arrive que
les cartons euros soit déchiré ma on en
perd ses bonnes sorties la compagnie et
je vous laisse à présent entre les mains
de la vitre pour le début d'accord
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir a tous fait une agréable soirée
les déchargeant politesse pour ducret
dur capitaine des rouges s'il vous plaît
capitaine la lna seul but que vous avez
récemment nous votre équipe riis
vainqueur après peut-être des bleus s'il
vous plaît et juliette seul vous pouvez
vous adressez à moi au nom de votre
équipe
c'est trop et remettez bien votre colle
dans ces cas là
[Musique]
très bon match improvisation mixte qui
aura pour thème la mito talent l'a eue
total nombre de joueurs illimité via des
gorille libre durée de cette
improvisation
or explique télévision donc on a promise
à sion dont on a eu le titre dont on a
eu le thème elle est limitée en nombre
du genre est libre en catégorie à la ccq
alors en fait ils annoncent déjà
premièrement si elle est mixte ou
comparer les allées mix c'est à dire
qu'on va mixer mixer les deux équipes
donc les deux équipes vont créer cette
histoire ensemble qui a commencé par
envoyer un joueur par équipe pour
commencer l'histoire un travail trop ide
et ensuite pourront rentrer
aléatoirement des joueurs d'une équipe
ou l'autre pour vraiment construit
l'histoire on verra la comparer plus
tard ensuite il annonce le thème donc
qui va être le titre voilà de cette
improvisation nombre de joueurs est
limité qu'il n'y a pas de restriction
catégorie il n'y a pas de structure jeu
et le temps trois minutes sera le bourg
et la durée totale de cette info je sais
pas vous rappeler que chacun de ces
matches vont durer 30 minutes que si
vous montrez votre bonheur à connaître
le prénom des joueurs
eh bien on va perdre un temps fou et
j'arrête ici c'est explique la soupe
parce que je pense que tout le monde a
bien compris ça va c'est clair si son
prénom est la toile celui que je n'ai vu
la dernière fois à côté de la rue à côté
mais l'arrêté la fin de la fête de la
rue allard non pas de la magie du tout
sûr de ma première
hu
non mais c'est pas dresser un incroyable
messieurs stoneham amour non mais j'y
crois pas en fait mais ça a l'air choqué
quoi ah ça veut dire ça traduit
champions contre pouvoirs très faible de
toute façon va ça veut peut-être dire
qu'elle était pas pour toi oui tu vois
là bas je me souviens toi avec antoine
+3 pb commandes et robben
tous les abus les deux hommes ouais nan
mais sérieux qu'est ce qui soulagerait
me sens très mal j'ai remué le nom
m'échappe mais moi je suis maintenant à
terme ou ces machines improbables
jamais vainqueur d'affaires sa spéciale
qu il toutefois
d'après m pourquoi tu le regardes comme
ça à vas-y palaminy
allez monsieur je prends toi tu peux le
faire
vas-y viens viens j'ai mûri je sais pas
bien mais ça peut faire mal à suivre
mais je tapais 14 moi j'aime pas ça tu
parfait gifi je devais l'agresser
on agit trop forcer tout est jaloux et
alana tu sauras tu me fous rires du
public confie t il pris c'est quoi ce
prénom mais je ne trouvais pas dans le
dictionnaire
apparemment tu fais un bon juge engrangé
un problème touche la suisse a passé
trois superbes suis tu vas pas comme ça
avec ok
ces chiffons me d'azur attendait surtout
des filles
[Musique]
voilà donc lire c'est la première
histoire qui a été proposé par ces deux
équipes la barre au sol et les pilotes
le trap
alors qu'est ce qui a bien marché selon
vous et qu'est ce qui aurait peut-être
pu être améliorée alors là du coup non
ça fonctionne bien parce que en plus
lâché je connais un peu des deux équipes
et les équipes qui ont envoyé un peu
leurs gros joueurs leur gros personnage
dès le début donc ça c'est à laisser la
place à la presse qu'une poutre qui ont
fais ci fais ça continue nous explique
une explication s'il vous plaît monsieur
l'arbitré bien sûr avec grand plaisir
alors c'est bien de rentrer comme ça
dans le match avec une énergie une
fougue un intense c'est parfait
simplement si vous êtes vous dépassent
plus personne n'y comprend plus rien ça
reste du théâtre et de l'improvisation
de s'il vous plaît prenez le temps de
vous partager la parole sinon ils
arrivent place hugues vos histoires
aimez-vous je ne suis pas sûr de savoir
pourquoi tout le monde se battait à ce
jeu-là de truc que je ne comprends rien
d'ailleurs des règles dépasse très bien
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
donc merci de canaliser un petit peu oui
voilà donc le lard pitre a expliqué les
fautes
c'est à alors il a triplé donc un manque
d'écouté aux deux équipes
parce que je te le disais là on a envoyé
on a eu deux très bons cabotin de
traîtres au personnage le problème c'est
qu'ils ont ils se sont un peu enflammé
n'ont pas écouté toutes les idées qui
ont été proposées ça donnait quelque
chose d'un peu brouillon à un moment et
donc du coup il est là pour calmer le
jeu est rappelé qu'il faut bien
s'écouter pouvoir jouer ensemble
évidemment en improvisation
et voilà donc le premier point pour
l'équipe de la barre au sol de quoi dire
ça fait 1-0 mais la maraude qui sont les
tenants du titre et les grands favoris
grand favori
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et donc l'arbitré houasnia cuvée à ce
que je vois là de marion sa collègue
catherine ouanna il faut savoir marion
collet c'est très ancienne dans le hall
a commencé à fourbe et ses premiers
cours donnés par un papy google
l'inde est l'un des fondateurs de député
à peu à courbet à la fin des années 80
improvisation comparer qui aura pour
thème mon recours en laponie nous retour
en laponie nombre de joueurs est limité
catégorie libre a duré de
l'improvisation
alors là c'est la première improvisation
comparer ça peut avoir la différence
avec la mx les mx donc du coup vous avez
vu les deux équipes jouent ensemble les
deux équipes en même temps comparé ces
on va désigner avec un palais un peu un
pointe au sein du coup on va désigner
quelle équipe va commencer l'équipe va
jouer seulement entre elles et en fait
on va voir une des équipes qui va faire
une improvisation qui va proposer une
installation une fois qu'elle aura fini
on va avoir lu la deuxième équipe qui va
proposer son improvisation à elle sur le
même thème et à la fin le public pourra
comparer les deux improvisations moment
du vote c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle
[Musique]
oh non
est ce qui a de quoi faire ronnie côté
bleu pour les bleus la vie est belle
générosité donc le village qui commence
si c'est comme ça que personne ne
m'écoute six mois à mater les batteries
négatif il est parti on est le 3e tour
afin non pas demandant plusieurs
responsables maintenant mais le père
noël vient répondre au rapport
il faut aller réveiller le père noël
excusez moi mais j'aime bloc
il faut vous faire pardonner qui
permettent le père noël bien sûr mais
vous que c'est jamais évident au final
on a fait trois pères noël et vous
l'écoutez jamais il en a marre que vous
faire parler
vous avez besoin 1600
[Musique]
alors quand il contacte parce qu'en fait
on s'emballe et les annonces et pasquale
commence
c'est un problème là tu as les marques
et camions et là y'a marqué pouvez nous
les anciens rebelles
oui mais camion c'est quoi le truc avec
sun salades des trucs qu'on fait c'est
le meilleur mais c'est pas là pour les
fracas mairie le truc qui avant mercredi
soir dans les trois cas là la lehman ne
s'agit pas de moi tout seul à la
rencontre ont joué ou là ce bal trad
sciure et 1
ils sont 30 à prendre en valais les
cadeaux c'est quoi ça à tunis où nous
tous
en plus vous essayez de me faire chanter
[Musique]
sans transition donc lormont qui planent
encore là mais la profitation mais jouer
à la manière des films arthur cherche du
couscous avec douleur
j'ai une famille dans une maison où
s'est pas trop fait c'est ça fait trois
semaines qu'il est parti n'a toujours
pas de couler si fram avis de grève du
lait va mourir
je ne sais pas il faut trouver votre me
faire face à la presse après oui c'est
qu'après mon frère je me souviens plus
du les herbes ont conjuré
un autre hommage de kato cette famille
cette famille nous on va pour essayer de
trouver une solution
qu'est ce qui nous reste on réserve une
à glace
écoutez je me sacrifie il a plu à la
magie de la glace je suis désolé je
m'excuse pour la glace tout haut la
glace voilà donc on a eu deux
propositions très différent c'est une
histoire avec le père noël est une
histoire gens perdus dans le froid alors
que l'arbitré siffle faute de confusion
si je m'abuse
je vais lui laisser expliquer sa
position
contre l'équipe des rouges
à chaque feu de confusion pour votre
équipe
par deux fois d'ailleurs une première
fois ou en fait vous annoncer que nous
sommes le 23 décembre et que nouvelles
aides en 22 heures et puis tout d'un
coup ça devient dans deux heures ainsi
c'est dans deux heures sur 24 et du coup
ça ne marche plus problème de décalage
horaire en laponie c'est sûr et encore
une fois parce que vous installez une
porte à laquelle on parle au travers en
mère noël ne sais pas où placer que vous
connaissez bien mais on va te croire par
cette explication
merci il est un peu tatillon il est un
peu tatillon qu'effectivement il emporte
avait été installé par une des équipes
et puis à quelqu'un que s'est présenté
devant comme si la porte n'avait ni ce
n'était pas il parlait à travers la
porte sans jamais expliquer que ça peut
être une porte très clean ou autre et
donc du coup et on ne comprend plus ils
sont à l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur et
c'est vrai qu'il faut être assez clair
sur le décor pour met en place puisqu'il
n'ya pas de vrais décors mis en oeuvre
pour que le public m'a donnée à tout le
public puisse vraiment l'imaginé comme
il faut il faut le présenter aussi façon
assez claire c'est un deuxième fois donc
qui est marqué par l'équipe de la mare
au sol et ja déjà ça fait 2 à 0 pour
l'ex improvisation mixte qui aura pour
thème trône éjectable crown éjectable
l'ombre du joueur illimité catégorie
libre à découvrir la manière d'une
épopée médiévale du raid à cette
improvisation 3 minutes et 30 secondes
or expliquent les mousses cette
catégorie lilian et pour pelles la
médiévale libre donc ils vont avoir des
directions de jeu est là la direction de
jeu la catégorie ses poupées médiéval
avec pop et médiévale c'est très simple
on découpe en deux il ya épopée
médiévale et autres et c'est une
aventure une quête médiévale au temps du
moyen-âge et donc ils vont devoir nous
présenter une histoire qui va présenter
aucune quête au temps du moyen-âge
saidal hier avec le vocabulaire qui va
avec les personnages l'environnement du
voile tout ça n'est pas respectée qu'est
ce qui se passait bien l'arbitré sifflé
une faute
nous on est de la même catégorie voilà
tout ça s'il y a un téléphone ou des
choses comme ça
[Musique]
il ya la musique médiévale j'arrête ma
marque côté tout est lié
ac n'a rien vu
il ne s'est même pas gouverner un
royaume qui ne veut même pas tout le
pays
j'ai une seule sûr vous voyez le trône
du roi oui eh bien j'ai compté quelque
chose qui s'appelle comme ça j'ai hésité
avec notre nom mais à la fin je me suis
dit par où sort sa femme vient c'est
pourquoi pas mettre mon prénom
ce serait les russes osk officie dans
marca avec un chrono de sue est donc
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas eu n'est
pas méchante
il faut juste des vins et des lettres
donc en gros comme on en aurait marre du
roi ou le la sir est dessus et ont eu la
joie c'est une matinée
- sanofi a une sous peu vous serez
bientôt qu'un roi je suis heureux
oui au trône les germaniques une et là
bas où ça relativement au bout je vois
rien là ta peau oui absous je crois que
vous prépariez tpf ohayon c'était café
ils ont regardé tous des mouches les
sexes le droit c'est vrai donc moi on
fait maintenant où il a essayé cette
mémoire les six mois déjà
heureusement sur ce siège mr tron royal
autorisé monsieur oui allez systems a
laissé le essayé sociale
franck kita se bat c'est dans ce cadre
en autant de royal le colline monde
c'était ta pièce tout ça non mais c'est
bien toi tu vois bien je peux vous savez
je suis plié
allez-vous vous allez bien manger
malakite à cause de fouilles j'ai eu les
fruits on devrait mettre ça sur le trône
du royaume
on met au rap
très peur
bon c'était pas la population à la
profitation de la profitation avec un
peu tourné voilà sur la fin je
n'arrivais pas sortir votre maman votre
décision est totalement avec cette
réflexion du joueur ryan leef un peu
déplacé des arbitres comme entre autres
le but est de une est excessif rend
votre joueur
ma foi c'était dans le débours et tout
je veux pu laisser passer
mais comme vous avez pu constater il a
outré le public
je suis là pour faire le party entre lui
et le public
en tout cas il ya d'autres manières de
parler à sa femme et aux femmes en
général c'est bien tombé de la part de
l'arbrisseau revient encore une fois
vous avez vu ciel
il rejette la faute sur le public et son
public ado comme pour protéger en fait
ce qu'il fait c'est qu'il protège les
joueurs comme ça la faute de ryan parent
est moindre à roger des prix alors là
notre décision mais a peu de temps
peut-être lynx mais c'est finalement
c'est l'équipe des rouges
donc le village qui marque son premier
point de la rencontre
ça fait deux pour les bleus c'est un
pour les rouges ça on a des alors on a
des très bons personnages depuis le
début une très bonne répartie par contre
les impros un peu plus longues ont du
mal à décoller
au bout d'un moment improvisation
improvisation mixte qui aura pour thème
la truie sélective la truite et les
petits
suivent reconnaître intéressant nombre
de joueurs nombre des joueurs ne par
équipes ya des bruits les bras durée de
la procréation une petite mine
ou comment on peut faire la promotion en
une minute dix ans serhat c'est très
court c'est très rapide
souvent on va jouer sur une rencontre
siècle et de produits et personnages là
en une minute succès mixtes ils vont
jouer sur une rencontre entre les deux
et on va développer plus une
improvisation de situation donc jouer
une sale situation qu'on va développer
qu'on va essayer dé tirer plutôt que
d'essayer de construire l'histoire on va
traverser des montagnes et des merdes
qu'on n'aura pas le temps en 1 minutes
de traversée d'un royaume aujourd'hui
deux joueurs seulement par équipes sont
autorisés à rentrer dans la patinoire
c'est ça c'est au noir et les deux paris
qu alors aussi là pas d'image c'est à
dire qu'on va avoir deux joueurs
effectivement pas avoir moins ne peut
pas avoir d'accord mais je ne trouve pas
la trouver la meilleure trouées pour le
président la meilleure
moi je vais vous la trouvez votre ont
tout de suite venu élu je suis et verne
on plonge pour commence vous avez juin
qualifié fiolet du relais
revient alors aux couleurs bad pas fade
donc les wii / tu vois là très clair
très guerre vient de tomber le lycée du
haut de gamme 6500 euros
on est sûr de la qualité la qualité
première
magnifique
la truite est morte ramé il a une tête
de quelque chose ne m'aura pas les voyez
on peut pas là on n'a pas le temps de se
compliquer en ville sans histoire voilà
il faut vraiment jouer les situations
avec des personnages à ses martyrs et
voit alors à qui va aller ce point pas
plus on va faire le break là
effectivement bourg l'équipe des bleus
au lancer de vente a fait droit pour le
collège de la barre au sol vous le
disais tout à l'heure un des grands
favoris
vous n'êtes de ces demi finales et un
pour l'équipe
du village improvisation comparer tu
rapportes m il était beaucoup trop
riches
dans son numéro nombre des joueurs est
limité
catégorie potes je piquais moussa
secrète alors les bottes secrètes c'est
chaque collège avec chacun de ses
coaches prépare une petite surprise une
petite botte secrète des petites armes
on se prête à présenter et donc du coup
c'est une catégorie littéraire et je
crois que la main au sol a préparé une
façon de jouer à la manière des oeuvres
d'agatha christie donc avec les tous ces
héros hercule poirot miss marple et en
face pour le village c'est à la manière
des oeuvres de molière voilà un peu plus
connus avec des oeuvres comme le
bourgeois gentilhomme les bris de scapin
et ils vont devoir respecter ce thème et
chacun à leur manière en respectant leur
catégorie merci beaucoup
[Musique]
suspense suspense suspense oh la la
c'est intense rebondi générosité
capitaine juliette est ce que vous
pouvez annoncer s'il vous plaît l'auteur
sur lequel il fallait improviser
agathe nous très bon choix et vous êtes
tous à commencer par vous vous étiez sa
voisine l'espagne
vous savez très bien à côté du corps de
monsieur abel j'ai retrouvé avec moi si
vous trouvez un bracelet votre nom
en revanche mieux possible ses petits
amis
j'ai retrouvé avec vous et quand je
repense à la saignée quand je repense à
cette scène je repense à tsn
je repense à cette série
très bien j'ai une position où nous voir
ces délits la crise pas nos merdes ex
mari
je le sens de votre visage plus s
nouvelle option attentivement vous avez
pour moi parce qu'un chapeau si sa
couleur ses collections du japon a
surpris de votre mobile
[Applaudissements]
et oui c'est moi oui bah oui c'est moi
[Musique]
je suis contre
c'était voilà 2019 pour les outrés on
est bardé woerth
il faut respecter leur taille à laquelle
on s'est un peu plus comique que les
soldats gardent et espère bien réel est
ce que tout le monde a entendu non
et baptiste poquelin dit molière on
l'est moins pour les moyens un très
grand humoriste c'est décidé vous ne
reviendrait jamais sur cette question
mais je n'ai plus à toi si vous lui
poserez je sais pas l'épouser si vous
êtes vous allez vous épousez avec il est
riche beau moi tu voiture justement
rehman chef du très cher que vous arrive
et se passe t-il expliqué ma mère de me
marier avec un dieu
juste parce qu'il est riche très riche
mais moi j'aime du stage le petit
moustachu çà et là
sylvie
ou comme un dieu
je n'en fais pas de ce mariage se
produisent déjà des mandats la route
franchement joli coup ci c'est moi je
vais même rien et que je suis riche et
vous êtes une bonne riche elle voudra
vous savez pas trop dire
je vais me plaisent marier avec lui par
quatre amis - diop
je dis seulement ce n'est pas moi
[Applaudissements]
ce rapport est le moins qu on refait le
monde le suit pas trop mais je vous
rappelle du coup mon cher nous a dit que
selon vous est il déjà vieux ouais
[Musique]
cgt réjouir que ça vous consoler aller
le vote là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le point oui bon les rouges ça fait 3 2
oui c'est des labels c'est vrai que
c'est la force des équipes aussi des
équipes dames et la diane que je vous
disais le calame formation classique
bien les auteurs classiques et l effet
très bien travaillé c'est un peu la
force de ses exploits là les thématiques
étaient respectées voilà il y avait du
vocabulaire il y avait les thématiques
du du mariage c'est exactement pour
retrouve tout en gardant la légèreté
puis le puncheur commission mixte qui
aura pour thème hôtel reine étoiles
hôtel l etoile nouveau les joueurs
éliminés catégorie libre j'ai de
l'improvisation
[Musique]
alors là pas encore parler de ce qui est
en train de se passer sur les côtés là
parce que c'est très rapide
le caucus le caucus alors pendant que
l'on parle en fait eux aussi et le
caucus ça sert à se donner des idées à
partir à vide et du coup c'est une
espèce de brainstorm pour savoir déjà
qu' on en voit quel joueur va rentrer en
premier dans cette patinoire pour jouer
avec l'équipe d'en face et le chargé lui
donner plein le plus d'aidé possible
pour qu'ils puissent se charger de ça et
ne jamais être à vide
une fois dans la patinoire même si après
le tout le jeu c'est aussi de comment se
détacher de ce qu'on a eu pour bien
écouter quand même la personne d'en face
et faire un mixte entre notre idée de
l'impro et l'idée de l'équipe d'en face
[Applaudissements]
bonjour oui bonjour je pourrais environ
ouais si comme d'habitude à
rapport à leurs interprètes de tri
problème lorsqu'il vous voulez
bon je vous attends oui dans le moment
vert
je lis vos un petit peu bizarre j'ai pu
enfin le soutien de bien être la laune à
l aigu plus sur eux
bizarre voire complaisante vis jetables
ou moins proche de roujan et très
glissant dans les temps sont durs
franchement je touche pas son nom il
émiratie un rire gêné bidon rire
les fier joaillier
réflexion j'ai sauté des infections
s'ils y changeront monsieur regarder sur
son corps est acculé maison bbc évoqué
jean c'est pop au moment où madame je
comprends pas vous dire vous avez six
ans
[Musique]
mais beaucoup de deux fautes ont été
sifflées l'art dégénéré
je crois qu'il ya une faute de retard de
jeu que je vous disais sa santé que sur
les 1 prend un peu plus longues on avait
du mal à se détacher de la pole ça se
rend compte et très bien on a eu du mal
à aller plus loin et je n'ai pas vu la
suite on va voir comment la saison va
écouter l'expiration arbitres un retard
que je suis désolé mais là vous vous
êtes plongés dans un faux rythme dans
cette improvisation
j'avais eu du mal à savoir qui était le
réceptionniste de l'hôtel est ce que
c'était le joueur monnaie ou la joueuse
de cyrine il ya une vraie confuse ramené
à partir on s'est compris même là un
pipeau il faut être plus clair qu elle
un petit peu plus vite et surtout
décider de ce pont appelons donc les
propositions qui sont faites qui sont
justifiées pour essayer d'un petit but à
l'emprunt pour toi bling il ya un
problème dans ma chambre
alors quand on amène une inspection
d'hôtel en hôtel 2 étoiles
on peut imaginer complètement miteux ont
bien pour inspecter l'hôtel par contre
une position complètement à côté de la
plaque
juste pour se tirer le têt les bornes
publiques et j'ai l'impression que là ce
n'est même pas complètement réussi
l'accord aucun moment donné notre
inspecteur qui s'occupe d'inspecter ce
qu'il est venu inspecter est pas le leur
est où est ce que je veux dire la cité
alors oui la ilaha illa il a peut-être
raison et c'est vrai que donc du coup
sûr ce retard deux autres et puis sur ce
personnage qui rentre et qui ne fait pas
avancer l'histoire en soi qui vient pour
essayer de faire rire le public avec des
propositions un peu un peu à peu à peu
nos employés mais mais voilà un peu
cabotine quoi alors c'est le premier
conte comptage de la totale à soi alors
en fait vu qu'il ya 500 personnes ce
soir quand une majorité claire se
détache l'arbite n'a pas de mal à savoir
si le vote est plus bleu un bleu au
rouge
mais quand tu ne sais pas il ne peut pas
vu d'oeil pouvoir détacher une majorité
puis demande à ses assistants arbitres
de compter chacun une couleur la couleur
de leur côté et de compte est réellement
il conclut en les embrassant vraiment
contrôler les 500 voix pour voir qui a
gagné en fait il vous allez voir ils
vont revenir les clients sauna une
ardoise pour ça soit visible de tout le
monde et on verra là au bout de ce
suspense qui en tant que moi alors dans
le cas où comme je viens de le dire la
rebute
il a ciblé un joueur qui apparemment n'a
pas fait avancer l'histoire mais qui a
tenté de se faire
voilà d'attirer les faveurs du public
est ce que ça peut avoir c'est justement
parce que c'est ce que le public va
voter pour des biens sur le marché l'a
fait partie de la stratégie je vais
prendre une faute mais prendre le point
qui va avec et ça fait une stratégie
globale bien sûr
on va voir si ça a marché ou pas c'est
ça marion coller mais un peu plus de
temps à noter que c'est peut-être un
clown une famille de mme horvath est un
signe ou alors elle a peut-être plus de
mal à porter rassemblement
[Musique]
ils ont voté
et les chauffer et ce sont les bleus qui
marque pour le collège de la mare au sol
et deux pour l'équipe du village c'est
donc le petit foot on dirait que c'est
le break à la wii c'est le brave surtout
que le match entre na vi et est bientôt
finie doit rester une deux afro maximum
m alors voilà c'était la fin il aurait
pu égaliser mais là c'est peut-être ce
qui a joué sur la stratégie puisque
c'était un poids très important très
noir est permis d'égaliser égaliser donc
des changements qu'on peut pas rester
sur une égalité évidemment qu'on aurait
le droit et l'improvisation
je pense à ces cours supplémentaires
pouvoir départager les deux équipes et
celles en effectivement à la main au sol
qui se qualifie pour la cour la fia nous
avons donc les premiers qualifiés pour
la finale c'est l'équipe de la masse
osseuse est donc la suite on va avoir
les deux autres équipes du mât et les
frais pour la deuxième demi finale
depuis
et bravo quand même assez du village qui
s'est bien défendu contre les favoris a
eu lieu cette année à développer un très
beau jeu qui se sont pas laissé avoir
ils ont réussi à mettre la construction
ils ont fait des très belles comparaison
aux normes notamment remporté leurs
comparer sur la molière donc on voit
qu'ils ont quand même bien travaillé
du coup dans une très belle demi-finale
ça commence très bien en vie
allez la deuxième demi-finale entre une
équipe verte qui est coachée par caroni
de marc donc l'équipe des prêts vous
connaissez les prés de monti le
bretonneux et en face il y a donc
l'équipe entraînée par alexandra penyes
telle équipe
du coup les alexandre dumas deux
bourreaux penser ça et on à la wii on du
côté vert donc car les marquis et
comédienne aussi des clips yade c'est sa
deuxième année de coaching dans les
collèges et en face on a adopté
alexandre baigneurs qui est la partie du
haut du pic aussi et en étant encore
dans les collèges elle était au collège
atomique
mais quelle ambiance s à l'improvisation
c'est aussi le fair play
ouais avec plaisir avec vous sega sega
continue
papapapa allait continuer quel est le
thème donc 06 60 mois les 50 ans j'aime
bien
sa vie est très à l'aise si très grande
comédienne aussi elle fait de la
direction de paris un pro à l'après 600
spectacles à sion n'attendent que vous
et elle à rire très reconnaissable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
civile je le fais que civiles ce
que vous avez vraiment votre équipe il
ya débat au nom de votre équipe et mes
frères tous improvisation mixte qui aura
pour thème le grand partage de l'univers
le grand partage de l'univers nombre de
joueurs invités catégorie libre à 30
secondes
et donc les presser leur comme leur
coach et leur deuxième participation au
cycle mythe alors que le collège
d'alexandre dumas sont là depuis le
début depuis 20 ans et je pense que
dumas même si la victoire n'est
qu'accessoire mais a très envie de
gagner puisqu'ils ont fini trois fois
troisième de ce tournoi déjà en 20 ans
et aussi trois fois deuxième mais ils
n'ont jamais réussi à gagner ce tournoi
donc c'est peut-être leur sens la meinau
mais c'est ça ils ont fini vous avez
fini 2e en 2007 et 3ème en 2018
ils sont toujours au top mais jamais à
la première place allez c'est parti pour
cette deuxième demi finale
cet hiver manque des planètes
il mange surtout le droit des femmes qui
peut avec ce nom toujours les pâtes les
hommes et pour les femmes
c'est une bonne question mais un petit
on va le dire un peu un petit peu de jus
d'orange
heureusement pour nous en étions les
hommes les a eus à l'éclat et les femmes
est bon avec la et pourquoi pas là les
femmes et les hommes non ça a toujours
été les avant-premières et pourquoi pas
les femmes mais cet univers faut des
solutions
voilà tu me dis je n'y vois les femmes
les hommes
mesdames on en a marre c'est fini nous
les avons la mort de virgile univers
tout ça on ne regarde plus fanas mais
après
l'eau en disant 10h10 et aux 10es reste
à voir
c'est toujours les stars qui font ménage
toujours les femmes qui vont travailler
à la yann rault plus je vous donne une
ère
bonne chance c'est la galère
j avais pas dit plus de planètes mais
c'est trop chine
on peut être libérée des femmes voilées
mal en mettant du coup c'est le même tu
veux pas je sais que j'ai un petit mot à
dire pour ce problème
la solution c'est que les femmes
deviennent des femmes et les femmes dans
des oeuvres et atteint les côtes sans
blague
les mèches j'ai décidé d'unir iphone moi
mais ils ont parfaitement faux écoute
sur la cas devenir des hommes ait
simplement garé
[Applaudissements]
tiens on du coup plus que la moitié des
universités des femmes et l'autre
voilà donc ce qu'ils ont proposé quelque
chose d'intéressant à la fin de la
prolongation
voilà pour retourner un petit peu la
situation c'est intéressant et c'est là
on voit l'intérêt de ce qu'on appelle
les troisièmes en très très bien les
entrées qui se font pendant la provision
tout ce qu'on a senti que les deux
joueuses étaient un petit peu un petit
peu bloquée un moment et l'intérêt de
ramener le troisième entre et s'est
proposé une solution pour avancer et on
a vu que ça refait décoller
l'improvisation est permis de jouer la
dernière minute au top
et vous avez vu ça a fonctionné puisque
ça a relevé cette improvisation
un peu plus loin
oui je te vois des voix
restait la catho
très sévère donc cet arbitre il en est
devenu oui il est le seul maître à bord
il veut le rester il veut que le vote
face à son signal wi et seulement merci
d'attendre mon signal il ya des règles
dans le vote dans tout bon d'ailleurs
alors je suis content parce qu'ici 1,28
iasc pour voter un garde et ça même dans
votre vie de tous les jours néanmoins de
prayssac samedi center est bon attendez
que je vous le dis votre vote s'il vous
plaît se permet de faire de la politique
non en fait il a raison puisque en fait
si les gens votent un à un
en fait ils peuvent être influencés par
les votes précédents aux ide en a pas si
tout le monde vote de ce côté là moi je
me trompe en votant en votant de l'autre
côté alors que le fait que tout le monde
vote en même temps de la même voilà
autant garde la même raison éviter la
voiture y en a d'autres à nationale b on
peut regarder vote mais c'est trop tard
on a déjà voté et c'est déjà un match
très disputé puisque dès la première
improvisation il ya déjà un titre wii
puisque aller jusqu'à user du punch et
des deux côtés la construction des deux
côtés que les deux premières filles qui
sont plutôt confuse lice pour ce prix
sera du coup et ses punchs qui sont
arrivés plus tard avec l'entrée les
garçons aiment ça on a partagé les
choses alors pour faire de la stratégie
on a coutume de dire qu'un match je
remporte sous les comparer suivant les
bon à l'unpi à l'autre et un match se
gagne sur les combats c'est pas toujours
vois pas ce que c'est quoi la
spécificité de la comparer ça permet de
permet de mettre en avant ce qu'on est
vraiment et qu'on veut dans son image
l'équipe pour son esprit à nous d'equipe
et ça permet voilà de développer
d'autres choses quel suspense mais
souvent ça une équipe qui aura plus de
bagues ou se fera plus remarquées sur
les sur les pompes à 193 ont les verts
140 le premier point c'était très serré
avec pour le collège du mas qui ouvre la
marque 1 point à 0 du maquis une équipe
très sympa à jouer
j'en veux pour quoi que l'année dernière
ce qui ont fini avec le trophée du
fair-play sa nomination comparer y aura
pour thème de la vache à la limousine
vous aimez les animaux
génial nombreux joueurs est limité
catégorie de comté du raid et à ta
provocation deux minutes et quinze
secondes alors qu'il convient de compter
les votes que salar l'avant ce qui
comptait pour moi c'est ça dont il
comptait en comparer c'est à dire qu'il
va y avoir un compteur qui va raconter
une histoire en avant scène souvent et
du coup le reste de l'équipe va avoir
pour tâche de présenter de jouer
l'histoire qui va être content et
attentivement parce coûte donc ça
demande une écoute en avait plus que
deux interviews à ce que chacun doit
participer à la construction c'est pas
le compteur qui fait tout et les autres
qui nous font que montrer sous un autre
angle
c'est vraiment le conteur qui propose
une idée les joueurs continuent
l'histoire la joue la montre et le
compteur de temps en temps relance un
petit peu l'intro pour la charge
je sais il envoie ses sbires aller
chercher son cheval et sa musique qui a
lui aussi participé au cycle vite quand
il était collégien
il était lui au collège que je me trompe
pas j'ai mes fiches il était au collège
de calgary et il a gagné le tournoi en
petit avec l'oeuf l'année où lequel de
tourner en tant que élève donc à 14 15
ans son coach était antoine le coach qui
était bluffante normalement au sol c'est
ça mairal bonjour tout le monde
aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter une
histoire je vais vous raconter mon
histoire ça se passe est un jour comme
les autres
à la ferme à travailler avec mes vaches
après avoir réglé mes affaires je
rencontrais une star elle devait s est
perdu mais non est lisse mais non mais
vous jouez dans diversion oui mais c'est
vous oui c'est incroyable
qu'est ce que vous faites ici dans ce
trou mais je vais revoir pendant un
tournage
si la digue et j'adore ça comme ça pas
justement j'aime bien les poches ebongé
tombent pas directement amoureuse de ses
stars ses oreilles ses cheveux sains
peau douce
j'ai jamais rien vu de tel vous êtes
seulement
grenoble se saurait
[Musique]
ah ben non bollywood ont tourné des
films balle et c'est super ça vous
quitter sa patrie mais c'est trop de
casse c'était trop ces trucs célébrités
pour moi tout ça là c'était trop pour
moi je voulais retourner voir ma vache
melba voulait redevenir de recueillement
je n'ai pas prononcées arrêtez arrêtez
scott toi viens je suis désolé fois
entre les chinois doivent ils ferment
tout grâce aux images le rappelle
j'étais dans un dilemme impossible a
heureusement j'ai décidé de la jouer au
jeu dit il est pile ou face
merci c'est moi où je me dufour s'ils
savent pas où je vais te donner du corps
aux 8e et n'oubliera jamais cette
histoire mais je préfère toujours ma
vache ma ferme et cette vie et c'est la
fin de cette guerre deviennent
importations champêtre champêtre une
faute qui a été sifflé mais on va y
revenir
oui une faute de cabotinage cabotinage
je vais aujourd'hui vous raconter
l'histoire de patrick un jeune fermier
qui vivaient dans une ferme avec sa fin
avec sa dette
patrick a adoré sa tâche
mais un jour quelque chose est venue
bouleverser leur quotidien une personne
venue de hollywood avec leurs
magnifiques nous il débarqua
tout est allé très vite pour l'alliance
ont adapté du conte blanche
perdu dans le fief même des chaussures
l'a dans la peau
les chaussures j'ai trouvé cette issue
mais vote
ça fait du bruit j'aurais vraiment à
faire elle pensait même à s'installer là
bas
écoutez je viens de très loin est
positif car j'adore les fermes du pool
lavage et tout le reste et je déciderai
avec vous tous les biens du mental dans
notre ferme
oui c'est d'accord oui et je pouvais
faire connaître cette pierre la star
aimait tellement le dernier mais le
fermier préféré vraiment savage c'est
mon amour un peu bizarre
une question est qu'est-ce que ça fait
si c'est moi
ce prix s'adresse à la sphère donc si
vous voulez me laissais ma tâche et puis
vous vous partez où j'étais je vous
avais déclaré lors de l'opération mais
qui arrive malheureusement un peu tard
je crois dans cette intro puisque une
faute de retard de jeu était sifflée par
l'arbitré yakine weeps car après
l'entrée de cette fameuse dame dans la
provision on a on n'a pas réussi à
prendre une décision à faire un choix on
est resté un petit peuple en paix sur
ces sur ses positions
allez un petit peu plus vite un dans vos
improvisation développé un petit peu
plus de choses et puis comme pour
l'improvisation précédente
attention de ne pas compter ses
dépositions d'accord et puis disent ils
mais déjà l'on 1 pour avancer dans
l'histoire
sinon vous allez nous rendre un petit
peu bêta ici un peu macho exactement je
suis tant que capitaine il ya une limite
au harcèlement qu'il est qu'ils aient
une part cela on peut être même un petit
peu c'est déjà trop d'accord
ne vous laissez pas faire j'étais obligé
de vous punir avec vos camarades
alors vous voyez vous voyez à quel point
ça déséquilibre notre société il faut
alors une faute de cabotinage d'anvers
anvers sa propre joueuses sifflé pour
l'épauler vert normalement on ne siffle
pas ce genre de chose en comparaison à
ce que à l'intérieur de notre équipe on
peut pas faire de vrais rudesse mais je
pense qu'il a raison de signaler que
voilà les les celui qu'on improvise à
sion n'est toujours un personnage on
peut pas servir de son très physique
donc du coup faire remarquer adapté
pixels mais ne fait pas partie de la
population tout doit être inventé tout
cela il ya un réseau d'escroquerie
le public a préféré à préférer la
promise à sion de l'équipe des prêts de
monter une boîte de doute c'est une
égalisation c'est pour leur part toute
[Musique]
improvisation mixte qui aura pour thème
et un défaut que j'adore - tu fous et
j'adore nombre de joueurs est limité
catégorie libre durée de cette
improvisation 2 minutes et 30 secondes à
les questions justement parce que o
on parle tout à l'heure de tout à
l'heure ces deux catégories libre oui
est ce que ça veut dire que les choses
les joueurs sont libres de prendre une
catégorie oui est-ce qu'il est peuvent
par exemple on achète tout à l'heure une
a4 à christine molière parce que selon
lui de refaire une molière ou n'importe
quoi livre il s'il faut ce qu'ils
veulent ils ont dit qu'ils auraient ce
qu'ils veulent
si un joueur veut arriver dès le début
en parlant j'espère briller à la manière
de molière pour essayer de poser un
univers où de rentrer avec un cow boy
pour poser un univers de western eux il
peut il est libre de le faire
c'est ça la catégorie libre comme le
fait bien souvent des équipes que le
faut comparer vivre souvent qu'ils en
profitent de cette liberté pour
installer leur propre liberté
merci
[Musique]
oui
je vais faire regarde moi je suis proche
encore je suis content je suis laide
mais c'est ce que j'aime chez toi
samet oui je ne lis pas les sacs de
toile verte
je bats
je sais pas moi je suis passé au vote
si tu veux
elle voudrait célébrer votre amour pour
l'éternité
[Musique]
monsieur paf
monsieur pascal vous épousez ont demandé
le marguerittes 2.0 le modèle marguerite
nous livre des oscars non tu es trop
parfait seigneur moi je savoure c'est
oui tu es parfait
moi je vois une femme nous voir dans le
miroir
regardez regardez vos proches et je les
regarde je me regarde tu me vois et je
n'aime pas
décision alors je ne peux rien faire
excusez-moi ya un autre voyage après du
quoi vous pouvez prendre votre avis
c'est plus important
non merci quand j'étais petit j'avais
pas fait faux j'ai fait exploitants
rochelle et rochefort
oui j'aurais dû garder mais personne oui
tous au lieu d'un couple parfait ce qui
fait qu'il ferait au mieux c'est glauque
au boulanger mais sinon oui c'est très
mignon tout ça mais en fait le temps
presse
je voulais vous répondez non épouse et
moi s'il vous plaît au tce tu le ferais
j'ai le pas est vite s'il vous plaît en
orage après on ne parlait pouvoir comme
double je vous déclare marié s'est
remarié
[Musique]
elle arrive la prétendante elle arrive
elle doit se faire belle alors rien a
ajouté qu'elle était sifflée ouest
commence par des trucs négatifs mais
c'était quand même c'était quand même
très drôle c'est parti oui d'un côté on
avait on avait le nolan lie le petit
qu'un peu la mascotte de l'équipe ché a
du mal à l'âge où beaucoup plus et on
peut suivre parce qu'on est demandé
c'est super les ellipses 1 j'adore parce
que ça permet d'aller beaucoup plus vite
dans les jeux
vous avez complètement perturbé les
joueurs qui tape ce qu'il avait une
décision claire nette et précise thomas
c'est une année dans le parc vous avez
surpris tout le monde avec cette
histoire de prêt qui officie pour
peut-être dans un parc mais comme il ne
l'a pas signé
tout ça est parti à vau l'eau arrêté sur
un vêtement
je dis les choses sérieuses deuxième
faute peut-être un peu cher je trouve ça
un peu sévère lui qui veut ça avance et
que j'ai pas de retard de jeu là au
moins ça nous confie sa couleur dans
l'histoire les traités ne leur laissait
le maître à bord de ses tâches il a
forcément raison et je disais on a d'un
côté nolan avec des personnages très
fort des yeux la bienveillance et on a
été ce côté là il veut ce très
constructif et puis après les deux
puncheurs qui sont entrés la tullow
amadou du côté à des prêts qu'à un gros
puncheur qui est vraiment le joueur qui
doit prendre les points et qu'elle est
très bon la barre et ibrahima de l'autre
côté aussi qu'elles puissent
expérimenter un m'équipe au club
mg on a repris le lead à la première
population mixte qui aura pour thème qui
est laid lui qui lui c'est une vraie
question
attention kasserine nombre de joueurs
catégorie et oui je sais rire aussi
on n'était pas sûr donc du coup c'est
bien de cette improvisation une minute
et quinze secondes
oui on en profite pour dire que c'est
l'équipe de tu connais avec son tube qui
a marqué le deuxième point de bon pour
leurs études donc ça fait 2 1 pour les
hommes je vous écoute non mais ça c'est
un exercice très compliqué là un seul
joueur ou une seule chose n'est pas
rentré paris qui sait ça c'est faux oui
privilégier les rangs sol je crois qu'il
a envie de le rencontre avec ces thèmes
j'aime tes défauts là un seul joueur par
équipe je crois qu'il veut voir là la
rencontre entre deux personnages ils en
vivent ils envie de voir ça donc du coup
chacun voyez ce que je veux dire là
chacun et chacune des deux équipes quand
on voit qu'un seul joueur on envoie son
que son nom de son dieu qu'elle est mal
j'ai des doutes avant soit viré il reste
combien de temps on attend bien oui de
la masse que c'est ce dont je voulais te
parler j'ai des doutes entre la russie
et les etats unis
je pense que nous espérons bientôt s'il
est possible et en tout cas il faut
arrêter cette et leurs masques gants car
s'il continue à faire des crises
un fichu déchu ce que tu m'entends oui
évident de crise cet arrêté
mais la fin c'est avec cet intérêt nous
allons visiter la france puis libre
jamais son père chanter allons-y
[Applaudissements]
vous disiez à de gros puncheur on a d'un
côté tom shelley dans l'équipe de dumas
un fan de the mask est hyperactif
voilà un très gros joueurs et enfin son
hameau amadou qui est pressenti pour
avoir la première étoile du tournoi
puisqu'il a été première étoile sur tous
ses matches sur préparation alors que
oui je vous dis deux très gros joueurs
de très gros puncheur et ça donne une
improvisation ya plus à faire une
histoire est une belle histoire une
histoire
voilà une histoire si j'arrive à
construire et à faire de la blague
autour de ça donc mon nom est très très
bientôt
très bien réalisé et à par des logiques
et cet homme grâce à sow voilà s'appelle
justin c'est ça sa chute de tibias ccja
permet de marquer un troisième point
pour le collège du mas a fait 3
annoncent à improviser à sion
improvisation comparer crème un
entourage oppressant un entourage
refusant donc des joueurs est limité
catégorie botte secrète durée de
l'improvisation 3 lui alors donnez nous
des deux votre secret s'il vous plaît
vivian d'abord pour le collège et
alexandre dumas alors pour alexandre tu
m'as la botte secrète c'est la manière
des oeuvres de marcel pagnol d'accord là
marcel pagnol donc manon des sources
puis château gloire de mon père le
château de ma mère pourrait donc des
histoires avec des des secrets de
famille voilà dans ceux de la france et
de l'autre côté un autre style on est on
appris georges en ouest du côté de
després donc des romans d'anticipation
dystopique un futur proche
as les noirs ou voilà c'est ça on prend
un aspect de la société condé fois on
nous comptons extrapole pour en montrer
la dangerosité
deux oppositions de style là clairement
on va voir ce que ce que ça donne
quelle équipe va commencer
[Musique]
capitaine où est elle je voulais c'est
très bien et je crois que c'était la
quatrième un beau marais c'est la
quatrième fois où les capitaines le
laisse se stratégique
c'est ce sera évidement vous nous dire
sur quelle hauteur valet improvisé c'est
ça j'espère que ça
il faur
t'as vu ça je vais pas du vrai c'est bon
voilà on se reparle ok on a dix minutes
merci
il ya acheté du projet règne accepte
toujours coincés retard et 8h 18h sur
les oreilles il est 22 heures mais y
croit mais nous la progérine nous aime
bien oui et puis on a fait savoir il ya
plus de vingt ans à faire une raison la
casinière assume son plan blanc c'est
bon faut aller
g
j'étais moi je vais nos serveurs on a
cherché du vin intéressant en deux
minutes les caméras passé sur hbo
j'ai sur wii vous savez que nous sommes
oui mais c'est du batin à genoux
les gens comme vous me dégoûte
les gens comme vous me dégoûte aussi
tout le monde me ravit alors une petite
rebelle javer torturer les gens comme
valérie va me booster nous on ne vous
inquiétez pas c'est la dombes de lui
alors de vous pouvez disposer pouvait
disposer quand je suis parti la
résistance de vous sait jamais
je ne sais pas en fait moi seul et je
n'ai rien peut venir à chaque partie
rattrapé la physique de compter encore
aller chercher du lait
mexico est là
on n'est pas que je suis vraiment désolé
je n'ai rien pu faire c'est également à
sauver mais ce que j'ai pu faire je sais
que j'ai mais vous l'avez dit vous avez
trois musiciens voilà donc pour
l'improvisation rejoindra bien
construite de george orwell des
retournements haut et très très
intéressant
cette simulation est annoncée sur quelle
odeur de l'impôt misé sur cette bagnole
marcel pagnol entendu me marier avec eux
plus en prenant un poney je n'y ai pas
les iem marcuse me marier avec lui
mercus oui c'est vrai qu'il est pas mal
mais qu'est ce que tu leur assiette
on croit à rien je les entends tu sais
d'où je suis le roi n'a pas parlé
et pourquoi mais pour que je le redis
épouse de papa-maman gm va reculer
d'ailleurs c'est ce que j'ai appris
toujours en ce moment je vais me marier
avec avec la fille d'à côté du oui
non je n'ai pas dans le mur j'ai une
solution trois plus forts d'une solide
je prétends pur de la ville aujourd'hui
en plein doute et gros comme ça tu vas
devoir ya la quinzaine un mois oui il y
avait comme données situées sur wii est
ce que tu me crois ce que ses parents ne
veulent qu'elle se maquille santo n'est
elle pas elle partie ancienne n est pas
mal mais je n'ai plus une fois dans le
pays 2 il faut se nourrir
c'est vrai que je n'ai jamais parlé
il saisit la balle que c'était les jolis
coeurs appartiennent comme je me suis
occupé de cette vie m'a trahi
robert bonjour
bon oui c'est moi ou négative on ne
mettra tous vexés donc maintenant avec
le domine donc quitter la ville
comment de sa voix que les rebelles
allaient par télé mais mon père n'est
pas qu'on n'a pas le droit de vivre
qu'ils avaient l'air est pas belle car
sa beauté en habitué aux étoiles et ont
passé seulement forcé
forfait bel univers la hausse voilà donc
deux univers très différents sur elle et
pagnol effectivement ça c'est différent
parce que le public a préféré c'est
toujours cool à 6026 force et ça revient
dans la dépose univers des deux côtés
moi je dirais que celle des endroits les
plus complètes parce qu'il ya une fin à
l'histoire alors que là on est sur la
fin pour les arbres c'est pas bien qui
prend quand même je pense que l'absence
de l'attaquant espagnol on a eu du mal à
finir et on a du mal à clore son
histoire et c'est pourtant bel et bien
sûr préférence pour l'interprétation de
george orwell je chasse est d'accord
avec vous sur cette improvisation et
bien c'est l'équipe d'alexandre dumas et
creuser car maintenant des cartes pour
la finale sur des sites où les jeux wii
j'ai bien peur qu'il ne reste que 12 2
offre au maximum et que on arrive à une
finale tu m'as maus mais quand j'ai bien
peur dont les peurs des contemporains
l'équipe d'alexandre dumas réussi se
qualifie tente ça et c'est ça c'est fini
voilà prévoit des études d'alexandre
dumas
bravo également à peu des prêts qui
appose également des belles choses où
ils se sont bien défendus de très belles
choses beaucoup une très belle deuxième
demi finale
ça promet pour la finale un là
et maintenant ce sont les finalistes qui
vont venir se mettre en place sur les
bancs comme en public vous apprécié
mais là ça promet on a on a d'abord une
belle finale au web et à deux unités des
univers différents qui sont déjà
dessinés et pas mal de construction une
grosse personnalité des deux côtés en
joueurs ça va oui ça peut aller très
loin très vite à mon avis ça va être une
belle finale
est ce qu'un avantage
à rester sur le banc et à avoir
peut-être une énergie voilà pour
conserve
est ce qu'ils se sont pas pour refroidir
les bleus il ya d'un côté on ait le
temps de se reposer garder un peu
d'énergie
mais je pense que oui l'avantagé quand
même à ceux qui qui reste sur le banc et
qui sont encore dans la dynamique du
match
ouais donc les bleus il faut le temps de
se remettre dedans de se remettre à
jouer tout ça tout ça ce n'est que de la
théorie un peu la version serveur nas al
marakbi
c'est ça c'est de la théorie mais ça
c'est bien sûr un vibreur est peut-être
[Musique]
un petit anecdote je peux me permettre
sur alexandra fusai je vous disais avec
giacometti à l'ail fini deuxième lors du
tournoi inter-collèges en 2008 est en
fait le moment de remettre les les
étoiles c'est jamel debbouze 0 mètres et
alexandra et fait l'erreur de 8 ans de
la mauvaise main pour lui serrer la main
et elle s'était retrouvé un petit peu
bête en face à face à sa dette qu elle
la france et l émotion et l attention
évidemment et or là ce sont tous les
chefs d'établissement et tous ceux qui
participent pour avoir dans les collèges
qui contribuent
à faire en sorte que ce championnat
inter collèges de battre des records
comme la papaye ce jeu poursuivent
depuis toutes ces années
donc madame devenir de la clé
saint-pierre vote à maçonner du collège
gagarine madame marcelo du connaissent
de la juan mata moniot du collège
champlain et champagne madame vautrin du
collagène albert einstein madame
chaillou du collège alexandre le débat
matam le moal et leïla deux collèges
courbet madame or en boucle tous
connaissent bien comme et tina death du
village madame laurent de caunes espère
se brise de la barre au sol madame
servant qui connaît ce décret madame
critères profs du collège des saules et
enfin pendant partout du collège
anatole-france
voilà vous allez c'est important pour
nous de de les saluer et de les
remercier va vraiment dernier match de
seraing tient une suite improvisation
mixte qui aura pour thème mamie
attractions
nombre de joueurs illimité catégorie
libre durée de l'improvisation
vous le voyez des liants il ya des
réactions du public dell annonce d'une
techno c'est quelque chose de très
important
oui il semble que vous avez en plus
participé à la confection des thèmes
oui j'ai gelé des gels un avis
consultatif mettant sur sur les thèmes
proposés ce soir
et parce que c'est jamais évident de
faire des thèmes de se renouveler dans
cette aide est ce que monsieur monsieur
noailhac et louise est il quand même à
plus de 500 matchs arbitrés
donc il en faut de l'imagination pour
toujours se renouveler proposer de
nouvelles choses toujours adaptés et il
le fait très bien vous avez vu encore
une fois l'action explique al anon de
ces thèmes qui sont très bien interprété
ensuite par les joueurs à l'essai la
finale et la première improvisation on a
toujours aujourd'hui le collège
alexandre dumas de maurepas et ample
bien sûr de connaître de la mare au sol
deux poignets voilé constructrice la
douche que j'étudiais mon rôle de
tessières je suis trop j'ai entendu
qu'on peut faire ça tu vas bien les
araignées trois temps ouais quand j'ai
vu la gravité
manger des serpents j'ai tout entendu
sur les toits
c'est vrai oui oui oui
et oui bienvenue un coup bas
je vais vous montrer tout ce qu'il a à
la voir dans le quartier alors vous
venez pour toi bien alors je vais vous
présenter
débat pas très aventureux le centre
ville et la campagne
vienne - la - c'est marine à présent
tenir le super parcours d'avoir trop
fort et bien super parcours des avoirs
et le supprimer on voyait les risques
onu mama simone est erronée
[Musique]
on avait un petit peu de temps à faire
cette proposition parce que le terme ces
thèmes amis passent à l'action et nathan
démarrer mon nez dans les 30 dernières
secondes grâce à la bonne entrée du
joueur nolan de dumas qui propose du
coup d'aller à l'action avec le parcours
de la mort mais malheureusement ça
arrive un peu tard un axe où la
mobilisation dure 2 minutes et laissez
moi vous dire que vous êtes passés à
l'action dans les cinq dernières
secondes 1 donc je respecte et elle est
surtout respectives tempo que vous
proposez le thème surtout vraiment donné
pour profiter de ces gens là ont proposé
des choses à voir au public
là vous ne faites que marleau en avion
pour rien
on se raconte nos vie d'avant pour rien
qu'on voit un gars ont réagi c'est super
il ne se passe rien finalement dans
cette histoire à part un road trip de
demi moore winona le thème demandé de
l'action et on n'a pas eu la pétition
secteur chaud mettons à dire des
championnes comme la première impro 70
se rencontrer de se mettre dedans
j'avais l'impression de la finale aussi
peut nier aussi bien sûr il faut pas
oublier que pour eux c'est une grande
pression et joutes face à et le premier
point est inscrit par l'équipe de la
mare au sol laisser la pression ce qui
tout comme face à cinq cents 500
spectateurs
j'ai déjà une pression pour un adulte
confirmée alors imaginez pour des élèves
entre 12 et 15 ans c'est une équipe
entraînée donc coach est pas pour
tourner antoine rabbo
[Musique]
improvisation au cobaye y aura pour
thème silex et autres inventions de
pierre silex était votre invention de
pierre nombre de joueurs toute l'équipe
catégorie libre durée de l'improvisation
45 secondes
alors là alors c'est la vocation de
gucht
on a eu cette fois là ça veut dire que à
mon avis fait ça parce que vu qu'on a on
a un peu tourné à pas en rond en apport
à l'anti jeu sur la première ligne mais
quelque chose de plus plus pêchus plus
court pour que les équipes proposent une
image parce qu'en 45 seront n'avait pas
le temps développé l'histoire note une
image très marquante très forte pour
accélérer un petit peu le rythme de ce
match et permettre à toute l'équipe pour
permettre à tout le monde de se remettre
dans tout de suite pour continuer le
match ensuite
c'est une improvisation comparez donc
chasser sa part proposé son
interprétation
[Musique]
vous voulez c'est le courage c'est le
courage très bonne a sonné son président
[Musique]
on n'a peut-être pas eu de silex dans
cette oeuvre en faveur de la misère et
une faute de procédure a été sifflé
l'équipe des jaunes
[Musique]
mais c'est monté et oui plus pratique
que le silex le briquet voilà c'est ça
elle y avoir au sol a tenté quelque
chose en instaurant une improvisation
sans paroles avec des hommes
préhistoriques on va voir si ça a suffi
à séduire le fictif
alors que on n'explique pas les fautes
il est pas la faute il ya une fois de
considérer légal qui est essoufflé la
police la rose c'est à dire que pendant
la colonisation développe son passé en
premier l'équipe des jaunes s'est permis
de discuter d'échanger des informations
donc le faire de prolonger son caucus
pendant longtemps ce qui est gênant ce
qui est une pièce est un tricheur un bon
pied c'est forcément interdit en
improvisation et vu que l'arbitré était
placée du côté du banc des jaunes il a
tout entendu hélas hélas
ah si c'est encore un décompte en a
compté décidément ces salons à la finale
ça veut aussi dire que le niveau de
l'été j'ai kiffé à ses proches a les
yeux ça reste que les départager
je trouve important
ça autant qu'ils sont en train de parler
bihan et moelleux
on voit quelques jours reposer quand
même des personnages qu'est-ce que ça va
changer concrètement dans une
improvisation d'avoir des personnages
très marqué alors ça nous fait plus
voyager sachant qu'on n'a pas de décor
on n'a pas de costumes donc envoyé un
personnage passe à sa relève un petit
peu la couleur de l'improvisation et si
on veut parler stratégie c'est la
profitation n'avancent pas ou si c'est
l'improvisation moyenne
le public se souviendra pas forcément
que l'histoire mais du personnage qu'il
a marqués et les buts où tout ça et
donne de l'intérêt au fait de faire les
personnages et puis c'est pour faire
voyager parce que si vous faites quatre
un pro de suite c'est que vous ne faites
pas de casse mais vous êtes toujours
vous même au bout d'un moment vous pas
vous tourner en rond mais qu'ils aillent
la scène publique
donc là ça permet de proposer des
univers différents
posez vous des questions régionales et
c'était très serré mais c'est l'équipe
des shows du collège d'alexandre dumas
qui égalise donc en leur esprit ça fera
moins partout c'est ça et voyez pendant
les les tangos l'arbitré choisi son
prochain thème priscu d'un petit peu
pour voir là l'astuce spectacle les
équipes sur les côtés notre pari à elle
danse comme ça ça leur permet de rester
en énergie et d'animer le plateau pour
mater se fasse rien pour l'instant sur
le plateau improvisation mixte qui aura
pour thème cuisine à la française
il ya beaucoup de joueurs limités
catégorie libre de la population
mais qu'est ce qu'il aura envie de
manger notre arbitre à cette heure ci
pour donner corps jamais question
également par rapport aux débuts de
limbourg mais ce que là on est dans une
catégorie mx donc et un joueur qui vient
au pied un caucus cas une idée qui a été
peut-être donné par un membre du groupe
et puis de l'autre côté il ya une autre
idée est ce que le but du jeu c'est
essayer de faire se rencontrer les deux
idées aux sk forcément quelqu'un bat qui
va lâcher puisqu'elle va suivre l'autre
non le but est évidemment de créer une
histoire qui va mélanger ces deux îles
et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont en fait la
la comme dire la technique la plus
partagée c'est que quand vous rentrez
sur une mx vous la première information
vous échanger ces informations sur vous
comme ça vous ne posez rien à l'autre
vous dites vous ce que vous faites là et
comme les notes disent qu'ils sont ce
qu'ils font là et ça qui est l'autre et
ça leur permet du coup de pouvoir se
faire se rejoindre les deux idées sans
empiéter sur le
ouais drake et lexine d'amour très bons
cavaliers vers toi voilà on est proche
creuser la marquise et tourné là ça
marchera l'amour trouvera les cieux sans
vous avec vous
mieux il est là et avec lui la route
fragile très pratique
je vote oui
non tous les bons coups verbaux avec qui
oui j'ai coché entendeur ou un long
câble public huit wagons chien je suis
père lemmouchia
chez vous
je suis juste chez vous et épouse est
épouse et moi qu'est ce que vous lui
commandait la poussée mancelle très bien
refuser aujourd'hui ces génies
l'excellent jeter pour sa superbe rôti
de porc foyer développer hostile à la
pour l'appétit si tu manques et moi
manger
oh
tac toe choix comme pour les maisons
[Musique]
j'ai dit j'étais bien avec mon chien je
veux chercher le plus vite là on sent
que la durée bon voilà on commence
vraiment à essayer d'élever le niveau
pour voilà c'est la flûte annoncé cette
émission c'est ça tout en restant dans
la construction jamais malveillance et
jamais contre l'autre mais en tout cas
voilà on commence à accélérer un petit
peu le rythme envoyez du répondant et
tout ça ça se sent à part des jo avec
l'équipe des jaunes
je connais alexandre dumas qui enchaîne
son deuxième fois dans cette finale
j'étais mené 1-0 et ça va tous se sont
pas démontés a fait 2 1 pour les jeunes
ouais là là il ya une bonne histoire qui
a été mise en place la avec cyrine et
nos lacs de l'autre côté et c'est sûr
que ibrahim a bien accéléré population
comparé rapporte m décisionnaires et
décisionnel nombre illimité de catégorie
poursuites
cette intronisation alors qu'est ce que
c'est qu une bourse suisse à leur
catégorie tu sais que donc c'est en
comparer une équipe va commencer une
histoire dont dix minutes 15 et au coup
de sifflet de l'arbitré elle ne va pas
quitter le plateau elle va se figer sur
place pour que l'équipe en face viennent
prendre position reprendre les
personnages qui ont été faits pour
continuer l'histoire avec tous les
personnages au moment où l'approché
arrêtés précédemment juste continuer
directement la suite la de
l'improvisation
donc ça demande des bons personnages
pour ceux qui commencent mais beaucoup
des coudes pour ceux qui vont continuer
l'histoire
attention 3 7 5 en hauteur règle c'est
la générosité la barre au sol qui
commence
je sais que si nous des bronchites les
faits les branches on sent qu'elle était
négative
cette personne une fois positif pour
mesurer les coûts pétroliers attendent
et posons les bases prenons notre temps
ok vas pas vraiment pesé le pour et le
contre pied alors qu'est ce qu'il ya de
positif
on s'est battu comme un homme c'est une
autre saison et demie qu'est ce qu'il a
fait pour la cia fait quoi à la hargne
en rien je sache propose qu'on la
franche et puis je sais que je pouvais y
étaient fondées sur l'école si ces
antisémites ou rien c'est les pompiers
bonjour alors oui donc bonjour adam
c'est quoi les produits d'archos
et là nous irons de la presse car la
ville un moment de la course sûrement
crise cardiaque
ça va bille du soir le marché est qu'il
est plus lourd mais non il est froid
moi je sais pas j'ai plus ne bougeait
plus les joueurs et joueuses une faute
de confusion l'a sifflé par là et nous
voyez tous les joueurs se remplacer un
par un si par des équipiers par les
joueurs de l'équipe tu prennes la
position qui était la prédiction ils
essaient de rendre le personnage est la
suite directe de 7 à 12 ans préféré à
glaçons non mais bien pour lui
elle n'a rien à faire là dedans nous
avoue venir la voilà qui fait tant rêver
en demande pour son permis il est
convoqué jeudi ses parents
c'est l'histoire qu'a pris un peu de
retard elles ont du mal à avancer dans
l'histoire là on n'aime pas la proposer
de nouvelles choses
ayem a été sifflé d'ailleurs où il faut
de confusion la technique pour les chefs
des bleus moi j'ai pas bien suivi mais
je crois que là à l'arrivée des pompiers
a priori c'était pas avec ce dicastère
non on va voir l'explication sa
capitaine mettez les mains d'une
improvisation que vont devoir continuer
les jeunes excuse moi vous les aidez pas
quand vous parlez dans le corps qui est
posée là et puis on imagine des branches
et donc on imagine comme on dit dans le
jargon a vécu un moment donné je pense
que quand des pompiers arrivent c'est
déjà beaucoup trop tard mais ce que je
veux dire
je pense que le caucus était peut-être
pompes funèbres
il y avait eu un problème de
communication sur vos devant les jaunes
ont dû gérer
merci capitaine brugeois et voilà c'est
bien ça donc c'était les pompes funèbres
ont peut-être traiteur d'attenté d'un
dentier
[Musique]
a priori je pense que tu m'as devrait
reprendre à n'ont finalement c'est les
bleus ce soir et bleu qui égalise qui
égalise le coup
[Applaudissements]
donc 2 ou un cours le collège alexandre
dumas de mon repas et deux points pour
le collège de la mare au soja va être
serré jusqu'au point de coignières ça va
être serré
ça va être serré jusqu'au maine séchage
concours tirer la bourre elle est
gentiment pourrait dire qu'ils se
rendent coup pour coup pour la sauce
improvisation comparé m pour tes yeux
pour tes yeux nombre de joueurs illimité
catégorie
you du ray j'ai pas vu le palais ducal
durée de cet impôt
promise à sion demi
et tu es la profitation chanter avec
accompagnement musical s'est appelé les
joueurs vont avoir des micros à leur
disposition et vont devoir faire créer
improviser une chanson sur scène mais
c'est un exercice très périlleux tutoie
apprécié des déserts promise à 13h
prophétisait ils aiment ça ils aiment ça
ils aiment se mettre en danger ils ont
pas peur et quand c'est bien fait c'est
très surprenant quand le saut périlleux
réaliser le public est souvent conquis
après ça puisqu'elle a contrairement à
l'improvisation classique on va dire là
il faut que ça suive leurs épouses de
toute la musique c'est ça tout le
l'exercice c'est quand même de réussir à
chanter de poser sa voix ce en écoutant
le rythme de la musique de la poser dans
le même rythme de construire une
histoire quand même avec son partenaire
tout en essayant en plus de rim est donc
ça fait beaucoup de choses à gérer en
même temps très bien
[Applaudissements]
c'est une malade que j'attendais bien
ils n'aiment pas besoin
[Musique]
vous attendez-vous coup de sifflet pour
mettre à chanter
monsieur les noyaux
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
tout tombe amoureux
magnifique
tout le monde est mal aimé
ayez
que moi
madonna
haché
pourquoi moi
suite
[Applaudissements]
elle n'a pas belle
m
[Musique]
râler
je ne
[Musique]
respect
c'est monsieur un gros des oiseaux
alors ça va tomber
or
m
[Musique]
lui
quelque part
[Musique]
le
bien réaliser des belles images là la
fin avec tes j'obtiens dénicher des
tubes jeunes a mis la barre très haut ou
très haut
donc on va voir ce que ça va gueuler
type
pour information les deux qui avait fait
la chanter à la finale déjà la dernière
fois cyrine c'était une très belle
chance et qui à l'été qui avait marqué
les esprits
donc on ne change pas une équipe qui a
les yeux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toi mon ami de tous les jours je t'ai vu
sa proie
on a mis
[Musique]
ce soir
il en a
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour moi
montesquieu pas quelque chose de
précieux
mais toi
je suis
la victoire
[Musique]
d'amitié
oui
[Musique]
la belle réalisation aussi la scène
exercice qui est compliqué là bas puis
on l'a vu carla qui arrivait à poser
leur voix
oui vivre c'est que le joueur il a
laissé réussissait à accélérer ou à
ralentir cette phase pour qu'elle rentre
dans le bon tempo en termes de pièces
alors que les bleus aiment alors cn
l'équipe des jaunes évidemment il
remarque que ce troisième plan et c'est
amplement mérité pour le collège
alexandre dumas y 2 pour le collège de
la mare aux soldats s'est mérité un
service mais ils votent la développer
une belle chanson mais malheureusement
elle bougeait trop et pour tout coup on
perdait un peu la voix dans les micros
tout le monde n'est pas claude françois
et pour chanter danser en même temps ça
leur a peut-être voilà aura peut-être
faisait un peu improvisation mixte qui
aura pour thème les lames du grand sol
les larmes du grand saule beaucoup de
poésie là beaucoup de joueurs est limité
catégorie libre durée de cette
improvisation
les larmes du vent au sol par rapport
aux saules pleureurs évidemment l'arbre
donc tout un jeu de mots et de la poésie
de la part de là alors là ils sont
libres de partir sur ce qu'ils veulent
oui on va interpréter les larmes du
grand saule ils peuvent pas d'accord ils
peuvent avoir besoin de faire pleurer un
arbre pour con côté je ne sais pas une
potion sakho et vont devoir console est
un arbre qui pleure ou alors larmes du
grand saule peuvent être respecte le nom
d'une grande personne chez sam pitroda
exactement et et voilà oui et on dit il
ya beaucoup de possibilités une
interprétation aussi
et vous personnellement quel est votre
catégorie d'improvisation préférez vous
avez vous laissé ça de préférer je sais
pas j'aime bien là la shakespeare ou des
choses plus punchy choix un joueur
plutôt punchy mois plus tôt kaboul
oui mon âme va être coupée en deux oui
c'est ça il faut que je trouve une
poésie qui aspire à d'autres chiens
j'espère
ils sont tous les maux que je me
concentre et cie ont demandé de le
déférer pour le way qu'elle me vérité
par contre comme ça coûterait trop cher
je sais que tu vois oui voila je trouve
patienter des gens là on doit noyer
collègues quelque chose chez airbus on
vous ne pouvez pas louper cette chose à
ce que vous ne pouvez pas j'ai pas le
temps il faut jamais avant de passer sur
le corps avant notre tous les soutiens
[Musique]
des terriers et que vous ne rateriez
dans mon jardin
aucune logique mais bon on refait une
santé maintenant
rip c'est dangereux et les papiers sales
et dangereux
[Applaudissements]
les larmes du grand saule
on aura attendu la fin pourquoi c lazar
mais à son arrivée finalement alors là
il ya deux possibilités soit il ya une
égalisation et oui si on arrive tous
ensemble qu'on arrive vers la fin d'un
modèle de cette rencontre
et là il y aura un poids pour départager
soit ça va du côté veut nous faire
vibrer
hélas oui c'est ça c'est mon ami si tu
m'apprends le point ils ont fait le
break lyonnais sera pas assez de temps
pour que les dépôts calamars aussi on
leur montre et si elle attend au second
point il égalise et ce sera du coup la
dernière proviennent souhaité être que
ce que vous n'utilisez tout à l'heure va
se confirmer parce que effectivement
l'équipe de l'équipe alexandre dumas qui
jouait déjà ils sont restés dans une
bonne élève
oui effectivement il continue et
peut-être que l'équipe de la mare au sol
un film à la fois la forme que ce soit
les joueurs ou même le coach il faut
remettre le cerveau en marche
et c'est toujours travailler
tu faisais beaucoup d'énergie en
première partie et donc du coup c'est
avec la descente se fait assez rude et
il faut remettre le bouton et c'est
compliqué de repartir tout de suite
repasser au dessus que dans bon sens il
faut quand même très bien sorti c'est un
match de très bonne qualité
[Musique]
si l'assistante arbitres du côté bleu
met plus de temps normalement soin et
les plus anciens étaient soi que je vais
m'attacher qualité soit il ya plus de
cartons et de scooters
l'amour
oui
[Musique]
les cas ces accusations cette équipe de
bleus eh ben mon avis on s'affairait
partout donc autant dire que cette
improvisation va être au capital d'union
louis on va voir
alors responsable quand ya un long jeu
comme celui là est ce que les joueurs
vont pas tout ça les aura on va danser
tout c'est parce c'est pour ça que
souvent dans ce genre de cas de figure
on met une comparé à la fin pour éviter
que chacun veuille tirer la couverture
et qu'on est unique ce qui tout le monde
tire un petit peu on aime comparer comme
ça tout le monde que ces réalisations
mix sur a pour thème profession
professeurs
[Rires]
oui c'est mourir je t'en prie nombre des
joueurs heureusement limités catégorie
libre a duré de cette improvisation deux
minutes et 45 secondes à 2 45 c'est pas
une supplémentaire elle avait sûrement
prévu le match en cette impro et que
sinon ça avait été une supplémentaire il
l'aurait ce serait un peu court pour doc
minutes 45 ans le temps de construire ça
exactement rappeler un petit peu le le
palmarès de ces dernières années à
divion
or vous avez carrément tout le talent de
tous ses voeux c'est à dire ça c'est
l'anniversaire aussi plus de ça fait 20
ans l'année dernière c'est l'ama
rousseau nous il ya quelques années pour
sa première participation l'année
précédente c'est dès le collège gustave
courbet de trappes exactement juste
avant cela il n'a rien amené ya besoin
justement effectivement le village juste
avant et puis on va coûter du corps
calleux
bienvenue rien je m'apprête à part ça
c'est vous qu'on fait du groupe
je me souviens de rien c'est les
vacances
moi personnellement je crois que je
passe le tout pour devenir prof de
français et je me souviens plus de rien
notre volonté de sortir de bons numéros
alors qu'en france à sa belle voix jeu
c'est parti at assurent-ils vous prenez
aussi leurs petits cahiers je voulais
jouer tableau aucun première en question
voulez vous aller mieux à lire au
tableau ça fait combien 1ère à tout ça
on fait pas surtout surtout sion allait
terminer me zapper ne finit pas dans la
peau souple elle allait deuxième
question qu'est ce que tu renonces été
question m'a causé paniquer
[Musique]
si je dis mon poids il faut dix avaient
boudé ces gens croient les goûters y
avoir un doute là dessus mais j'avoue
j'ai triché coupées plantes est
également passé à la deuxième question a
cherché à lui à chaud j'ai lutté un peu
au plus que c'est sûr je vais y répondre
et à la fin je suis elle a dit je suis
je suis
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or moi j'aimerais quand même saluer le
comportement du coach alexandre un
peigne est oui c'est une finale il ya
deux joueurs bleus qui étaient là mais
elle a coiffé d'envoi l'impôt se
suffisait est enfin en vente tous
auraient mangé du temps et voilà ça
serait peut-être surchargé
l'improvisation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maggie dont une procuration
parce que dans le bureau de l'arbitré
non non je n'ai pas choisi l'autre s'il
vous plaît votez votez votez et la coach
alexandre à un petit un petit rituel
avec le joueur tom but là les cheveux
relativement pas un peu long c'est
toujours elle ils ont pris l'habitude
c'est elle qui lui attache les cheveux
avant chaque match comme un rituel avant
d'en avant chaque match on est ok ya des
rituels intérêts sont réparés long ça
arrive comme partout côté familial et c
'est toujours bienveillant mais on les
soutes nos élèves c'est assez nos
petits-enfants à nous et voilà on aime
bien qu'il soit dans un cocon dans les
meilleures conditions
alors enfin temps il ya des enfants en
question soit différent maintenant à eux
il y en a certains qui ont décidé d'en
faire leur métier qu plus en faire leur
métier
oui certes vous avez aussi des joies
comme caddie d'antoine qui ont commencé
aussi cuite en tant qu'élève ou
alexandre alexandrov qu'ils sont
maintenant des comédiens
je décris qu on a même eu à tence ya un
coach qui sont maintenant plus ou moins
reconnus à des coups de théâtre
on a par exemple vous citez publicité
des noms si je les trouve ici on a des
joueurs qui ont été dans baby évidemment
qui a agréé l'équipe cabaye qui est mal
ce qu on a des gens comme un n 10 pi
mort il s'adonne bien aussi qu'il ya un
ancien coach ancien comédien théâtre et
un autre ça mais rossi qui a officié sur
les bancs de la patinoire ici même pas
car il ya du beau monde qui est passée
par là
décidément la cie store pyramide est
excellent a calculé csii code beaucoup
plient
marion collet qui a une excuse oui on
attend à nouveau la félicite
cela ralentit causer chez soi dans son
bunker à la city un lot plus de valeur
[Musique]
et encore une fois s'il y avait plus de
temps à mon avis je point capital
également parce que ça aurait pu être le
dernier
oui ça va être et ce avec un wanna go ça
fait quatre points à 3 pour le collège
de la mare au sol et trois points pour
le collège alexandre dumas tension s'est
terminé alors je regarde oui j'ai vu un
terminé cela il semble que ces terrains
est la maîtresse de cérémonie va ça va
rentrer va s'appliquer à la rentrée dans
la patinoire
c'est fini sur cette improvisation la
rue elle va s'arrêter cette finale très
serrée de finale
il ya quelque chose contre les
propriétaires des autres sachant que le
public ne va pas savoir tout de suite
qui a gagné puisque ça sera annoncée à
la toute fin
dans le garder le suspense
[Applaudissements]
oh
j'en pense
on arrive à prix sonné
c'était chouette et je ne vous dirai pas
tout de suite qui a remporté ce 20e mais
c'est plus icmi tu ne me donnes non non
vous aurez beau insister c'est non oui
vous insister lourdement m'enfin bon
place au suspense et et au prix de la
saison
et oui comme de coutume il y avait aussi
une personnalité d'honneur chargé de
remettre les étoiles de ce soir aux
joueurs et joueuses qui selon elle se
sont le plus distingués sur la patinoire
aujourd'hui ont été remises par valérie
le prieur professeur de lettres au lycée
de la queue-lez-yvelines improvisatrice
et trésorière de déclic théâtre aux
peuls applaudir celle boucle dans le
prieur que vous connaissez bien puisque
elle était à ma place il ya quelques
années les avc c'est exactement
l'excellente vannerie le prieuré nous
embrassions bien sûr troisième étoile
est de couleur rouge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elena capitaine de l'équipe des rouges
des renforts alors les étoiles c'est une
sorte de classement pour ce seul
objectif c'est déjà fait une seule
personne qui les remet donc c'est
forcément subjectif et et on fait c'est
pas un classement mais c'est pour
essayer de le leur dire de jus doré
qu'on prendrait contact et voilà que les
autres n'ont pas été bons mais ces
histoires de mettre en avant c'est
qu'ils sont sont fait mieux sorti sur
ceux sur cette rencontre
même si je trouve qu'ils ont tous fait
une très belle finale la joueuse demain
lakhouad et alexandre dumas glas des
empires 26 sexuelles entre eux oui très
constructrice l'âge aux civils auraient
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
porte le numéro 20 seychelles juliet
snowden coque de l'équipe est encore une
fois la capitaine on le sait ça fait
trois fois que c'est le capitaine prend
pendant ce temps les trois oui donc
peut-être que chez les verts qui est le
capitaine chez les verts près que tu as
une chance fait que genève a une chance
d'avoir cette fois-ci banon
euro disney bondit de 10 en valeur
c'est une très très bonne à la fois que
le numéro 10
ibrahim c'est ça
[Musique]
amplement mérité il a pris une très
belle chanter aussi donc ça a marqué les
esprits ça aide d'avoir aussi une perte
pour voir deux numéros
c'est une bonne surprise
oui mais effectivement suis assez
d'accord avec ce jouet ferment
clairement c'est un joueur serbe qui
s'est pas forcément montré partout tout
le temps non ils ont été pertinents 80
d'avortement exactement il a fait des
très bonnes entrées il a trés d'apporter
les infos il a réussi à être boc à
apprendre les pois faire rire le public
a fait réagir le public tout en faisant
de très belles constructions souvient
notamment sur la george orwell
son entrée est capitale pour la rentrée
d'un produit et il a fait divers est
bonne avec du championnat n'ont parfois
moins oui bien sûr du collège des prix
continue proto et commençons avec le
trophée du fair-play trophée de votre
partenaire tune qui récompense l'équipe
qui a fait le moins de fautes sur ses
matches je vais appeler le président de
déclic théâtre monsieur dominique
charrier pour remettre ce prix
dans le trophée fair-play effectivement
alors on l'a vu pendant cette soirée il
ya des fautes qui sont sifflés par par
l'arbitré ça et à deux équipes qui voit
là encore beaucoup d'autres
et c'est cette équipe qui l'a remporté
cette année c'est ça et c'était cette
année c'est je sais que chez nous et
pourtant ils sont faits seulement
seulement de cette année voit tous faute
penser ça exactement 12 à deux fois et
du coup il s'est très peu puisque ses
prix sur l'ensemble des quatre ou cinq
matches de l'année à l'équipe
youri gagarine de trappes présentant oui
je vois cette équipe n'a commis que 12
fautes depuis le début du championnat
est quelqu'un qui a été une bonne équipe
est une équipe très agréable à jouer à
tout moment de l'année
[Musique]
l'équipe coachée comme tout les comme
tous les collèges de fraude par hamel a
dit hacker et dont certains étaient aux
trousses et votre fait national aussi
ont fait culture est ouverte itcca
trophée culture d'improvisation donc le
président de déclic théâtre dominique
charrier acquis les résidents qui porte
vraiment les valeurs de deux théâtres
les représente un peu partout en france
et à l'étranger
les régimes c'est un prix c'est vraiment
un prix important fait du fair play en
improvisation parce que ça montre que
l'équipe travaille bien respecte fait
tout pour bien respecter les règles et
du cou et une équipe agréable à jouer
agréable à voir jouer
voilà donc c'est vraiment c'est pas un
prix
à un prix pour l'auguré les
chrysanthèmes route c'est vrai un prix
très important que rire on a proposé
c'est un l'entrepreneur qui vient de
drap woman
voilà qui a créé cette maison d'édition
avec saisie pour ni son formidable
je vous demande d'applaudir très fort
hamel antoine attendra les blessures lis
que je crois que vous êtes appelé j'ai
choisi je me retrouve seul merci c'est
sarah tout en vous amusant sortir
[Musique]
pour moi ce sont les étoiles du
championnat qui sont remises aux joueurs
les plus étoilés de la saison et
intervet longtemps dans tous les
collèges tout au long de l'année
c'est bien sûr les coaches les
intervenants des collèges ramel antoine
alexandra libye en mario caroline et
tommy sites sont attribués à
tu es morte du collège albert einstein
deux pas du village de trappes alexandre
de la géode elancourt basé beaucoup fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc on le voit tous les élèves
filles et garçons qui ont participé tout
au long de l'année à ses ateliers à ces
matchs intra ya l'étoile du championnat
reviennent à
mais voilà une belle récompense
également pour eux ça récompense un
travail de toute une année
et bravo également à ces deuxième étoile
[Musique]
il arrive récupérer leur trophée avec un
grand sourire
[Musique]
bravo petite photo pour les applaudir
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
ce sera très jolie dans nos chambres et
ceux et celles qui repartent avec la
première étoile du ciq mythe
les joueurs et joueuses qui ont été les
plus récompensés de cette année sont
[Musique]
nous
toit du collège du mont nebo à mano
negra
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà donc tom du collège alexandre
dumas et mohamadou du collège les prêts
à montigny-le-bretonneux
voilà les deux joueurs qui ont brillé au
firmament pendant toute cette saison
2018-2019 de cette 20e édition du
championnat inter collèges de match
d'improvisation théâtrale
bravo à eux ah bon collègue est de
retour je me sentais un peu seul
division j'ai bien fait d'y aller a
beaucoup d'émotion je laisse aux
rebelles sunnites
pour remettre le troisième prix ces deux
nouveaux dominique charrier qui va le
remettre
dominique est en place
[Musique]
ils nous ont offert un spectacle de
qualité ils n'ont pas démérité
il s'agit du collège les prêts 210000 le
collège les frais d'eau qui viennent une
place par rapport à l'année dernière il
avait plus de 4e maintenant tous deux
sont troisièmes
donc voilà on va suivre l'évolution
peut-être 2e et 1er d'appareils pour du
coup pour que dumas
équipe entraînée par caroline marre oui
[Musique]
elle est très bien travaillé toute
l'année c'est seulement leur deuxième
année en corse
bah oui seulement leur deuxième elle si
ça découle un horizon bien avoir ces
sous les bons conseils de caroline la
deuxième 6 mars ont été les spectateurs
ont tout d'abord parce qu'ils
connaissent déjà le vainqueur de la
finale
j'en compte
[Musique]
ils ont eu la chance de jouer la finale
de ce soir et se sont inclinés par un
score de 3 à 4 il s'agit bien sûr de
l'équipe du collège de alexandre bien
c'était c'était vraiment serré à lyon où
le dernier vote s'est fait au total
d'eads et les incite pas envie que j'en
avais l'occasion au sol et bien jouer
des matches nuls
voyons reste à l'époque et j'ai en tout
cas la bonne règle cette finale elle
s'affaire au mieux coup pour coup des
très belles personnalités très beau
personnage tout en essayant de
construire on a eu de très belles
finales il révèle deuxième place pour le
collège
il ya eu un beau parcours du monde selon
dan et aussi vite
vous le disiez n'ont pas encore réussi à
avoir cette première place non il n'ya
jamais bon il ne dément pas enfin trois
fois 3e 34 fois 2e battement grand
gagnant de cette 20e édition
j'appelle
monsieur ferry petit roux maire adjoint
délégué à la culture aux fêtes aux
cérémonies et oni verrouille toute la
ville de trappes
monsieur philippe cartiaux n'étaient pas
bienvenus ils sont donc les vainqueurs
de cette vingtième de ce 20è asik mythe
il s'agit bien sûr de l'équipe c'est à
doubler sa taille en termes
footballistiques de la barre au sol est
on peut juste et c'est très belle équipe
une jeune équipe la victoire en 6e et en
5e
donc avec une très belle marge de
progression feu au cul là leur deuxième
année seulement aux cyclistes changement
ufc a seulement et donc du coup déjà de
très belles progressions des très belles
personnes des élèves est impliqué
présume 1
non vraiment une très belle équipe qui
compte n'est pas atteint
par antoine c'est un comédien de talent
que ça fait là dessus et série ryan
marque esteban juliette et nathan caezar
et et tous les autres dieux comme un
tueur antoine darbois et on n'oublie pas
effectivement il y a plus de six joueurs
on allait dire je sais qu'un oui les
anglais sont 15 éclate comment on voit
là bravo à toute l'équipe
c'est un travail et équipe avant tout
fièrement l'inventaire dans les night
amplement ajouté et voilà la peau de
balle en profite pour remercier tout le
monde et va très bien l'équipe technique
de la mairie
oui qui fait attendre on remercie bien
sûr toute l'équipe de t'exciter
interactive chloé sophie chantal claire
d'aurélia king julien pour la
préparation de cette belle soirée
merci bien sûr hâte et d'espoir sont
18es et toutes ses équipes techniques
autour de romain russe pili mercer
voulait vivre merci merci à vous de
m'avoir reçu j'ai adoré commenter ce ses
matches avec vous ces vagues de qualité
on va passer un très bon moment de faire
obtient donc du tout aimé rhône avoir
invité merci en tout cas un client les
prochains rendez vous aux dépens d abord
vous allez sur les réseaux sociaux
vous tapez soit déconnecté à pourquoi
les poires vous tapez des critères sur
le moteur de recherche de tous les
réseaux sociaux que vous connaissez et
vous tomberez directement ses voeux et
roux s'il vous plaît allez on va finir
justement avec les mots mais deux
nouvelles soirées n'est ce pas quel
talent
quel talent
c'est un grand plaisir à chaque fois de
vous voir tous ici de voir ces jeunes
qui nous émerveille le temps d'un
spectacle et je dois retenir une chose
quand même qui est importante c'est
qu'elle fair play on a eu le premier
prix du fair play mais quand même quel
fair play et je pense que nous les
adultes on peut prendre exemple sur vous
1 je pense qu'il ya des moments où on
devrait savoir faire comme vous parce
que ya plein de gens qui se disent
qu'ici rien de ce joug qui c'est pas
grave mais si tout se joue ici leur
avenir
l'amitié la fraternité le courage parce
que c'est pas toujours évident de
d'affronter sa timidité et puis et puis
on va dire quand même le vivre ensemble
tous ensemble
toutes les villes et on va aller encore
plus loin parce que je vous rappelle que
trap est la ville du monde de l'impro et
merci à détecter après avoue 12
avant de vous laisser repartir
je voudrais remercier tous nos
partenaires
le commissariat général à l'égalité des
territoires
le conseil départemental de la pauvreté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines la ville trappe
la fondation culture et diversité
la belle santé notion ping la marine est
particulière dans l'équipe merci donc à
bignan parisien a doublé qui te décris 4
avec la participation des bouées et j'ai
peur de trappes qui fut sa télé ce soir
coeur qu'avec les mains merci
[Musique]
l'appât du gain
hbo vient après
[Musique]
bonsoir merci laetitia lui sur est
excellente
istres est serbe no mercy encore une
dernière fois et lilian et à bientôt
pour encore plus d'improvisation vers
civils y ont rien à faire vous à voir
avec l'équipe donc qui a remporté cette
20e édition du cycle mythe ça vaut
quelque chose en puissance et les vingt
ans cette année un petit cri de guerre
pour l'équipe de la mare au sol 2 one
year c'est vraiment le où il fait partie
du truc elle et juliette raconte-moi
possède cette finale c'est demi finale
et cette finale fait deux années de
suite donc le match était super cool
hésiter qu'elle et ses autres équipes
étaient super forte et on s'attendait
pas du tout à être en finale et les
matches étaient très serrés donc on s'y
attendait pas du tout c'était pour la
finale en ouest était vraiment c'est bon
on est resté dans le jeu à fond et puis
et puis c'est vraiment à la fin l'effet
de surprise on s'y attendait pas
forcément et on est super heureux parce
que bath en plus c'est la deuxième année
du coup voilà et et voilà c'est super on
est très très très très content
qu'est-ce que vous avez aimé dans cette
demi finale est dans ces finales ben en
fait c'était chaud c'est vrai que comme
l a dit marion s'attendait pas à gagner
et bah c'est plutôt l'effet surprise
qu'il vient en fait il ya quelque chose
qui se passe aussi avant parce que vous
rencontrez avec les autres équipes vont
partager tout ça c'est important si
savants dans cette soirée
bah ouais super important surtout que
bah du coup on partait avec tout le
monde donc en fait c'est plus une
réunion de famille en fait on est tous
est en train de jouer enfin c'est hyper
cool du tout enfin ce qui est bien on
n'est pas du tout en compétition ça qui
est super super intéressant du coup dans
le théâtre d'impro la rencontre avec les
odeurs du coup c'était super mais qu'est
ce qui va se passer l'année prochaine
ben autres à notre tournoi et on espère
une victoire bien sûr
fall effet la place un peu à l'étoile
raconte un peu cette aventure parce que
toi tu laisses eu depuis le mois
d'octobre
ouais ben moi j'ai je tiens à saluer
d'ailleurs l'idiot mézières qui les ai
l'année dernière et qu'il les a bien
formés les petiots c'est super grand
chose à faire en vrai je m'asseyais dans
une salle et je les regardais jouer et
ça suffisait largement ils se sont tous
très bons
il ya un très bon groupe mais ça reste
très important et là franchement ce soir
je pense que les quatre équipes étaient
hyper homogène ça a donné des très
belles rencontres
et voilà je suis très fier de mes petits
de la mare au sol voilà donc c'est la
mare au sol qui fête les 20 ans du site
mythe
effectivement effectivement c'est
quelque chose quand même un voile à
faire il est passé par le site mythe
également oui en fait il ya longtemps
oui en 2005 il avait d'ailleurs pour la
tis c'est leur année de naissance
merci en tout cas tout le monde
félicitations à bientôt le collège
alexandre vous êtes deuxièmes mais vous
nous avez offert une super finale qui me
racontent un peu cette soirée
bah ouais j'ai bien aimé franchement
comme c'est ma dernière année j'ai kiffé
j'aurais pas je remets c'est à dire plus
longtemps mais comme d'habitude bas
honnêtement j'ai bien aimé cette finale
franchement même les demi-finales des
tout le monde c'était sympathique
voilà j'ai moi aussi je pouvais leur
faire de leur frère mon vrai mais je
suis fier de ce qu'on a fait on
finissent deuxièmes promet même 4ème
c'est pas grave racontez-nous qu'est ce
que ça vous apporte de faire de la pour
la toux clavier bâle un point ça me
donne de la force dans la vie ça c'est
quand je suis énervé je fais de l'impro
j'ai tu as l'air très calme bah oui mais
maintenant on a fini deuxième je suis
calme mais voilà je fouille je pense
arriver troisième voire quatrième parce
qu'elle dernière j'ai pas participé à la
finale j'étais dans le public et bat
jérémy participer et là je participe à
la finale et puis ça fait du bien et toi
qu'est ce que tu as aimé dans cette
finale
bah moi j'ai aimé de tout d'abord déjà
tout ce que avec qui en a joué
enfin bon c'est super bien entendus dans
les coulisses ils étaient tous
sympathiques et a pas eu de problème on
quoi on s'est très vite très bien
entendu donc déjà ça déstresse pour
pourquoi jouer ensuite sur dans la
patinoire puis ensuite ça a un truc
incroyable parce que je pensais pas
qu'on allait arriver deuxième et puis
comme a dit ibrahim conçoit 2e 4e ou
quoi l'important c'est qu'on s'est bien
amusé et voilà vous êtes belle amusé à
c'est le message que tu leur as donné
alexandre est là pendant toute l'année
ah bah évidemment de toute façon je
pensais même pas qu'on allait être
qualifiés on arrive ici donc je leur ai
dit écoutez c'est déjà super hein ça va
suffire
et puis on va s'amuser au final en
partant comme ça on arrive deuxième mais
que demander de plus donc voilà fier
d'eux bon quand même
on doit le dire c'était très serré à
cette finale en a qu'on a cru un moment
que ça allait basculer du côté des
jouets c'est vrai que nous on se taquine
beaucoup entre coaches donc on faisait
des pronostics dans les coulisses et ça
fait un peu un petit moment et donc du
coup là je vais aller embêter antoine
parce qu'effectivement c'est eux qui
nous colle est prêt et pas l'un vers
donc ça fait plaisir mais effectivement
l'autre équipe et les super forte super
sympathique on s'est vraiment éclaté un
petit cri de guerre pour terminer
ok merci à tous
salut voilà mesdames et messieurs c'est
ainsi que se termine ce 20ème
championnat intercollèges de match et
d'improvisation théâtrale diffusé ce
soir sur tv 78 on se retrouve l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition
[Musique]
mais pour viser
m
à
[Musique]
le soleil est ce arrivé fait enfants
réchauffer la chaleur et toutes
présentes et j'ai envie de dire ouais
il fait beau